Morning everyone up my name is
under Tom Umberg. And I am very
pleased to be here in Long
Beach other purposes hearing is
the show off Long Beach new
city hall- I know the mayor
would appreciate that- so-
before we get to the panel
members would like to do is I'd
like to recognize the mayor of
Long Beach. Of Robert Garcia.
Mayor Garcia did you want to
say a few words. Well thank you
senator and I one of course-
first welcome- some great
friends and of course- leaders
in our state that are working
on very important issues but
especially one other interests
all very much which is the
census- I want to first welcome
you to our new Long Beach I.
Civic Center. Hi this is- one
of- of three buildings that are
currently already built as part
of the civic center this is our
city hall building a right
across is our our harbor
department which is part of the
city are our port. And then our
new I. Billie Jean King central
library which is just down the
way- and soon- in between the
structures will be our a great
park for the community as well
as some- housing much of which
will be affordable so we're
we're excited about this
project and thank you for being
here- at the Civic Center. I
want to just first say on
behalf of- of the council and
all of us here in Long Beach I
we want to thank you for the
incredible work that's
happening around the census-
we've been telling our senses
team here at the city that
there is no bigger issue. And
twenty twenty then for us to
ensure that everyone is
counted. And the ramifications
as we all know- that will
affect everything that we do.
All of the funding mechanisms
and programs are critical for
us to get the services that we
need I'm in a good count I'm is
not just about representation-
it's about finding it's about
equity it's about ensuring that
people get the social services
that they need- and it's making
sure that we know who
completely is a part of our
community. I will share is you
will know that we are
incredibly- concerned about are
harder to count communities. We
are incredibly concerned about
ensuring that all people-
including those are documented
in our community or a part of
our our census count. I mean
we're very grateful to the
state for the significant I
really think it's significant
funding and support. Has come
down from the governor and the
legislature. We want to be. Our
partners are I am very proud
there's a lot of folks that are
here. I'm in in the audience
and I recognize that are part
of our- complete count team. I
think Long Beach is a great
model we have a complete team
we have a broad. A coalition of
community organizations and
labor and business and
nonprofits and government.
Other working together to
insure that everyone is
counted. I'm and the last thing
I'll say is. I was reading an
article this morning in the
paper and I'm I do know that
while lot of our a larger
cities seem to be well
organized- still need I think
up and down the state. Are from
four from some smaller
communities some communities
with large hard account
populations that don't seem to
have yet- even a coordinated
within their city- to help with
the census and so I'm really
hoping that. We're not just
probably looking at a larger
cities but that every single
person up and down the state I
gets counted. I'm sorry I'm
just thank you for being here-
in Long Beach center I'm bird
we're very grateful you
represent a part of our city
and to everyone else thank you.
But in the long Mitchell thank
you thank you mayor Garcia and
merit I want to. One applaud
you but but I also want to
thank you. For leading by
example- you you've been a
great example for other
community leaders other mers
run the state of California. In
terms of both the importance of
the senses in the investment of
both personnel and treasure.
Into making sure that we do get
a complete count and so on
behalf of. I'm gonna. Take the-
up to thank you on behalf of
both committees for your
leadership thank you thank you
much. Thank you mayor- we're
we're pleased to be able to.
Hold this- joint meeting of the
assembly select committee on
the senses the Senate select
committee on that. Twenty
twenty United States. Census I
am most grateful for other
committee. Co chairs being
here- some remember mark Berman
from up north from from Menlo
Park- recently recently moved
to Menlo Park is that right
yeah two weeks ago. And senator
Richard pan from Sacramento in
our esteemed colleague. Related
to Russell here from Los
Angeles- before we begin I'm
going to ask if the- members
here of the committee and we're
I think we're gonna be joined
by US senator León consolidate
some point in time here today-
if members of the- select
committees would like to make
opening statements let me first
turned to- senator pan. And
then to assembly member Berman
and then to our colleague
Senate Russell. Thank you very
much- Sir- Burke and appreciate
your- continued partnership as
a co chair of the Senate select
committee on twenty twenty
cents a somewhat thank. Your C.
and the people of the city of
Long Beach for welcoming us
here to have this hearing
today. And what they call the
witnesses who are joining us
today for our fourth joint
hearing on twenty twenty
census- nor past hearings have
provided a general overview of
California complete counts
program operations strategy in
funding and fact most recent-
hearing focused on language
access. This hearing we're
gonna be hearing from both the
Los Angeles and Orange County
partner to learn more about
outreach strategy in this
particular region I think more
specifically. Also interested
as we are approaching really
the US census when- happened I
mean we're just months away.
Think about it's not that far
away. To be sure that we have
this is the appropriate-
interface- between our- the
people on the ground in the
community the- local entities
like is the- the counties and
other partners in the C. vios
and the state. And to be sure
that- we have- clearer lines
of- expectations and lines
responsibility- between- each
of the different entities I
realize that may be different
in different areas- I think I
appreciate that the mayor of
Long Beach brought up that. No
one perhaps in some cities
where there are you know more
organizations and people to
working a longer. May need-
less help from it's a state or
regional entities whereas other
communities may need more
assistance. But we what we want
to be sure those especially we
talk about the hard to count-
we can't let people fall in the
gaps because of organizational
problems that we have so- I.
John eager to hear how both-
what's happening here I won't
call a microcosm given how big
LA in Orange County are it's
America because of the state-
but I think you- this hearing
will hopefully set the two
counties as examples of. How
we're all this is all starting
to come together in preparation
for the count in April it's
again not that far away so
again I really appreciate this
opportunity to hear about. How
this is going how we're gonna
reach the hard count have a
going to. Reach the variety of
different communities we need
to count in order to be sure we
have a complete census. Data
like to- turn it over to- and
the chair of the assembly-
committee- and my good friend
so member Berman thank you so
much. Thank you so much larger
pan and center amber again and
the mayor Garcia and the city
of Long Beach. For hosting us-
as we all know the status can-
committed considerable
statewide planning and
resources. Towards the
achievement of a complete and
accurate census count in
California. However while
planning and resources are
important. They aren't enough.
We know that success will be
decided by what is actually
achieved at the grass its roots
level. How well we do in
reaching a complete count will
be determined neighborhood my
neighbor. Street by street in
door by door. If the census
ever were a basketball game. I
know basketball's cool again in
the LA Long Beach broader area-
then we de and during the third
quarter right now. The freight
Beth was rough in northern
California right now I'm a
little. It's nice to be down
here- this it will be entering
the third quarter right now-
the first quarter was spent
identifying the challenges
developing relationships and
building a plan. The last six
months the second quarter was a
bit more operational as we've
begun the on the ground work.
But as we enter the third
quarter the three months
leading up to census day. It's
critical that we pause we
evaluate what is worked what
hasn't worked and what new
challenges have come up that we
didn't anticipate earlier. And
improve our plans before moving
forward so it's kind of similar
to what coaches and a team I do
at halftime. For example today
we will discuss how to solve an
urgent need. For more census
enumerators who serve an
essential role in contacting
our hard account communities.
While the numerator recruitment
and hiring technically falls
under control of the U. S.
census bureau. This is quickly
becoming a risk to the entire
success of the census which is
a problem for all of us. I hope
to hear that our senses
partners of the state. Local
and community level will step
up. To help get this effort
back on track so that we can
all accomplish our goals.
Similarly this is an
opportunity to learn about what
is working in Long Beach. Or
Los Angeles Orange County and
see if those efforts can be
replicated in other communities
across California. If we're
going to accomplish this if we
are truly going to critically
evaluate our progress and make
the improvements necessary to
achieve a complete count. Then
this must be a time for open
and honest communications
freely given cooperation and
expanded inclusion especially
the potential contributors were
still on the sidelines. So it's
my hope that today's Frank and
honest conversations will help
us in that effort. Thank you so
M. member Berman and now let me
turn to our our colleague
senator Russell. Great thank
you very much. Thank you chair
number again. My other brothers
appear- I just want to mention-
center- Bergen night we're on
the Senate budget subcommittee
and I chair that- subcommittee
number for where we had a lot
of testimony come before us
from organizations community
organizations from really small
rural towns in central
California- to the larger
cities. And our what I remember
distinctly in our conversations
which was why we pushed an
added an additional thirty
million dollars to the
original- proposed budget. Were
a few things that stand out in
my mind one is that the media
and communications strategy was
not going to be limited to. The
usual maybe one or two or three
languages that there was going
to be a serious effort to
getting into building language
capacity in some of our
smallest areas in the state- so
language capacity and the use
of media. Very very local-
media outlets and
communications methods- had to
be used- and that was one
reason why we needed to push
for additional funding the
other is examples of the trust
messengers the trust. Is built
up in certain areas which is
why I was pushing for- the
schools to get more funding-
there's not a single community
in the state that doesn't have
a school. Is not a single
coming in the state- where
parents don't trust the
teachers and the administrators
they rely on them they count on
them. And so communicating a
message of importance and
urgency are on the census-
comes more powerfully through
these messengers that are
trustworthy along side of
course our community based
activist- our churches of all
faiths. There's other ways as
well but I just wanted to
emphasize those as some
examples today I hope. To get
up to two things where are we
where do we stand and what we
need to do in the remaining
short time before the census
actually starts- hitting our
our communities and our and our
residents. I appreciate- that
there could be a lot of phone.
Speeches on the importance of
the senses but I think we're
past that. Everybody knows how
important the censuses what I
really want to hear today is
where are we what we need to
know it's urgent we're really
down- as assembly member Berman
said we're really down to the
last- critical moments so- I
hope that- I know I intend to
listen- as much as possible.
And I hope all these issues are
covered thank you very much.
Thank you senator Russell and
we're pleased to be joined by a
Long Beach is on senator-
senator Gonzalez a good follis
welcome. Thank you and you'll
have to pardon my sickness I've
got a little bit of a cold but
I'm really happy to be here and
thank you to senator Umberg and
pan and- simply member Berman
and- US senator the Russell for
having me I'm not on the
committee but it's really great
to be here especially-
representing the thirty third
Senate district that
encompasses most of Long Beach.
And southeast LA a where we
know is the third- to be
affected- relative to the
census and the number so in
addition to the importance
absolutely we want to make sure
we're on the same- consistency
in messaging and that we're
doing everything we can for
communities so thank you very
much again for having me here.
What well thank you all- it
it's a hundred days until the
census. Really begins our
nation's say it that way
because the preparation and
the- anticipation and the
planning. Began quite sometime
ago but until of the actual.
Starting gun sounds it's a
hundred days so in the next
Hundred Days a tremendous
amount of effort and tremendous
number of resources of both
devoted by the state as well as
local communities to make sure
we get a complete count- I
know- miss Carnegie is heard me
I know she's going to testify
little later on mentioned
several times that that one of
our concerns one of my concerns
and make. Sure that that we
have accountability so that all
the resources that are going to
be poured into this effort are
are going to be used most.
Ifish efficiently as is
possible and so today I'm gonna
ask questions with respect to
metrics questions with respect
to accountability questions
with respect to transparency
and how we can make sure that
we get a complete count- and we
make sure that the taxpayers-
the- there. Funds with which
they entrust us are spent
efficiently so having said
that. Let me now turn to the
first panel- we're we're
pleased to have- let me
announce who's going to be here
from Los Angeles county. Of
Jana your eBay chief executive
officer strategic integration
branch. Of the city of Los
Angeles marina del- lose
Garcia- director the census
twenty twenty initiative from
the Los Angeles mayor's office
of budget and innovation. Also
on city of Long Beach Kevin
Jackson deputy city manager
city Long Beach. From Orange
County Molly Nicholson on the
public information officer on
behalf of the CEO of the county
of orange. And from the city of
Santa Ana our own daisy Peres
senior management system. So
let let me begin with miss- you
Rebay- if you like to kick it
off I'd be grateful. Thank you
the floor is yours good
afternoon chairman number
chairman pan German Berman the
members of the committee. I am
with LA county chief executive
office thank you for the
opportunity today to share the
county's efforts to educate and
encourage our residents to
participate in the census.
Today I will be addressing how
LA county the hardest county in
the nation plans to meet the
challenges we face with the
census. We've already
documented our challenges so
now is the time for action and
thanks to the support of the
state legislature and the
California complete count
office we have the resources
and support needed. To launch
LA county's twenty twenty
census education outreach
campaign. The twenty twenty
census was always going to be a
major challenge which would
require collaboration and
strong partnerships. As
mentioned in past testimony to
the committee coordination with
partners locally regionally and
statewide has been a
cornerstone of the county's
planning efforts. As outreach
efforts move forward into
twenty twenty. And implemented
the county will continue to
work closely with our partners
including the city of LA. Long
Beach California community
foundation LA regional census
table the state census office
in the US census bureau. In a
variety of key partners
including city schools higher
education businesses chambers
and unions. Beginning in early
twenty twenty the county will
launch a local comprehensive
multi lingual media marketing
and community outreach
engagement campaign with a
focus on our hearts account
populations the plan will
consist of. Paid earns an
ethnic media digital tool kits
lie branded events. Mobile
census action kiosk and
targeting messaging
highlighting local county
programs that belie on census
data. The size and scale of our
campaign is directly dependent
on financial resources and
coordination with the state's
own media and marketing
campaign. The county looks
forward to continue
coordination with the state in
that aspect. The county
recognizes that one of the most
significant resources are count
our county departments and our
work force with over thirty six
county departments and a
hundred and thirteen thousand
employees collectively we have
the capacity. And the resources
to reach our ten million
residents. And educate them on
the importance of the census
for example the department of
public social services touches
nearly three point five million
clients many of them also cover
hard to count populations.
County departments to date have
submitted out reach plan
develop unique strategies
targeting are hard to count
population Anil corporate
census met messaging and their
daily interaction with clients.
Whether resident is receiving
public health services at a
clinic or excess scene are
assessing the variety of social
services our county has to
offer. Our dedicated work force
will educate and motivate
residents in the places and
spaces they visit. In January
twenty twenty will also launch
the county census champion
program encouraging all our
employees to take the census
pledge to ensure their
household. Families friends and
communities are counted. The
county is administering a
prophet two thirds of its nine
point four million allocation
from the stent from the state
for outreach efforts and our
sixty seven cities and forty
five on a corporate areas that
have part two count
communities. Fighting
allocations were based on data
measures develop by both the US
census bureau and the state.
The county is contracting
directly with two of our
largest hard to count cities
are here with us today Los
Angeles and the city of LA. We
gave the remaining cities the
option to either pull their
resources with the county. And
be eligible for a compliment
services including digital me
I'm media took its direct mail
campaigns are earned and paid
media out reach. For those
cities that choose to take
their funding allocations. They
can develop their own out reach
plans but they have to follow
state and out- county
requirements this is to speak
to set certain cities are
actually kind of. More poise to
implement census out reach so
we wanted to kind of be mindful
that give cities the option. Do
the digital by that still exist
in limited access to broadband
internet packing are hard to
count populations. The county
together with the city
developed a robust listing of
potential sex census action
kiosk and questioner assistance
centers. Which are locations
where the public can access an
internet enabled device
developed the census or get
their questions. About the
census answered. County
locations will serve as
questioner system centers and
be stopped by train county
employees. Given the recent
state issued cat guidelines
wrist regarding C. A. keep case
and Cubase sees issued by the
state will have to probably
make modifications to that
program according to how we
originally envisioned it. The
county wide complete cow
committee call led by the
county NC a have been engaged
is engaging various sectors.
Higher education subcommittee
develop a tool kit for average
to students and school
administrators and we're proud
to say that was actually shared
statewide. We will also be
developing and distributing a
tool kit with ideas for
businesses of all sizes on how
to incorporate the census into
their activities early next
year will be sharing that with
our partners in local cities.
We're working closely with our
unions include the SEIU to
conduct outreach. In
coordination with the Los
Angeles mayor's office last
week we held a briefing with
the counselor core offices in
LA county to bring them up to
speed on our local planning
efforts. Together with first
five in the LA county office of
education we also convened our
state partners and local
partners to discuss and share
our reach targeting are zero to
five population in our case the
twelfth. For the county these
are the following key issues
moving forward. Counting the
homeless population. LA county
has the highest number. Of
people experiencing on
sheltered homelessness in the
nation and as such counting the
population will be a major
major challenge under the
census bureau's current plant
operation. He partners
including the city of LA Long
Beach as well as L. A. homeless
services authority and C. C. F.
in the state census office have
met with the census bureau to
learn more about. Their process
and how we can work together to
address structural barriers
berries to county this
population. The county is
appreciated that the state
yesterday issued their final
requirements and guidelines for
the C. A. Kays and Q. AC's. The
county will continue to work
with the state to comply with
these guidelines. To host are
these locations the total
number of locations is
dependent on this. Over the
next fourteen weeks it will be
critical for the recruitment of
applicants to be hired as a
numerators. With the positions
for the US census bureau to
assist the US census bureau
with this efforts our own
county department I. workforce
development agency your
services. Will be conducting
six recruiting and pre screen
events this month with American
job centers of California.
These events in partnership
with the census bureau being
held in hard to count areas
with one being organized
specifically to recruit
veterans I also want to. Note
that we're working closely with
the city of Long Beach now late
to also kind of help support
these efforts to hire
numerators. At the county in C.
sample continue to work with
the states communications
office and media contractor on
coordinating our media plans.
We look forward to receiving
the state specific local media
plants given the substantial
effort necessary to operate
operationalize these programs
in the region. We understand
that the planning for the
twenty twenty census is a fluid
process. And we respectfully
quest the state continues to
consider. As out reach to
homeless. Additional security
in language access measures at
our questionnaire assistance
centers and kiosk. Additional
Andy Murray a numerator
recruitment. And unforeseen
challenges during the non
response follow up period. In
closing we recognize the
importance of our local efforts
and how they will impact
political representation and
federal funding for the next
decade we appreciate the
state's second commitment to
ensuring a complete and
accurate count in Los Angeles
Los Angeles county. And look
for to continue to work closely
with our friends at the state.
Thank you. Thank you and in
with the my co chairs
permission what I'd like to do
is have- the various panelists
testified save our questions
the end all right there seems
to be consensus thank you very
much next. Miss some read the
look. A loose- Garcia from the
city of Los Angeles thank you
thank you for being here.
Fuhrman's Amberg pan and Berman
and members of the committee
thank you for giving me the
opportunity to share with you
an update on the city of Los
Angeles's. Outreach efforts for
the twenty twenty census I'd
like to thank the governor's
office in the California State
Legislature for investing a
record setting amount of funds.
That has enabled our outreach
efforts. The city of Los
Angeles began preparing for
twenty twenty a full three
years ahead of the census.
Among mayor Garcetti's first
actions was to issue executive
director of twenty one. Re
establishing the office of the
census instructing all city
departments to designate a
census liaison. And to develop
action plans for conducting
census twenty twenty out reach.
The core premise of our
approach is based on
collaboration from the bottom
up. For the first time in Los
Angeles is modern history we
partnered with the county of
Los Angeles to form one single
local complete count committee.
To coordinate outreach efforts
avoid duplication identify gaps
and leverage resources. Since
establishing the CCC we have
worked hand in hand with all of
our partners county of Los
Angeles the city of Long Beach
California community foundation
Los Angeles unified school
district colleges universities
businesses and blossom. To
launch a comprehensive and
coordinated outreach campaign
in the city of Los Angeles that
aligns with the states Richard
Fritz. As this twenty twenty
census approaches the city of
Los Angeles will be focusing
its work in six areas. One
recruiting training and
deploying a legion of
volunteers who you're calling
senses goodwill ambassadors
that are themselves considered
hard to count our volunteers
will lead peer to peer out
reach by organizing and hosting
events within their networks
and neighborhoods at census
action kiosks and during our
get out the count canvassing
efforts. We had a goal of
recruiting four hundred census
goodwill ambassadors and I'm
happy to report that we have
already exceeded that goal. To
date we have recruited and
trained six hundred and seventy
nine volunteers. Through more
than twenty training sessions
across the city. Thanks to the
generous support of the Roth
family foundation and the
mayor's fund for Los Angeles we
have been able to provide
volunteer appreciation gift to
volunteers. And many grants to
organizations which I believe
has helped to boost turnout at
a recruitment and training
events. Our program is
currently on hiatus for the
holidays but will resume after
the start of the new year. To
establishing census action
kiosks in city facilities where
people can comfortably and
securely fill out their census
questionnaire. We have
identified a total of one
hundred ninety five potential
CAC locations in this in city
facilities and nine hundred
over nine hundred have been
identified county wide. Thanks
to the partnership that we have
with the county of Los Angeles
the city of Long Beach and our
community partners. The city of
Los Angeles is currently in
conversations with the
California complete count
office and the county of Los
Angeles. To ensure we can
provide support to the state as
the rollout the questioner
system centers in question
suspense kiosk guidance. On a
parallel track we're working
with our city departments to
conduct a readiness assessment
in anticipation of these
guidelines. Depending on the
outcome of those guidelines we
may need additional funding to
maintain the scope of our
county wide program. Three
leveraging the city's
infrastructure by disseminating
information through city
department programs and
services and placing localised
advertisements on city owned
assets. Such as street polls
buses sanitation trucks out and
outdoor digital billboards. A
few of those departmental
highlights include. The
department of water and power
is going to be printing census
twenty twenty messages on
envelopes that will be sent to
one point six million
households. And bill do this
twice during the self response
period. Our sanitation
department will play census
twenty twenty posters. On their
fleet of refuse collection
trucks. Our workforce
development department is
working with the bureau to
conduct recruitment events and
they've held fourteen. Up to
date. A street lighting is
gonna be placing five hundred
and seventy five signs in St
polls that are going to be
located in hard to count
neighborhoods. Transportation
department is placing ads on
the bus tales and videos
messages inside local buses.
Are information technology
agency will be adding a
recorded census twenty twenty
message from the mayor for all
calls to the city instead of
hold music reaching
approximately seven hundred
fifty thousand people. And our
three one one telephone
operators will ask callers if
they have completed the census
during the response period and
if they need help will direct
them to additional information
reaching approximately one
hundred twenty five thousand
people. Supporting an for
supporting and fostering on the
ground out reach efforts by
community organizations via the
Los Angeles census fund. A
grant making program
administered by the California
community foundation designed
to fund CBO's conducting on the
ground out reach efforts in the
city of Los Angeles. Five
promoting enumerator
recruitment by amplifying and
supplementing the federal
government's. Efforts via
targeted Meryl and departmental
communications. Six conducting
direct out reach to
historically under counted
populations and geographies by
attending and hosting outreach
events. A non gap area is
engaging our residents
experiencing homelessness what
we are working closely with the
Los Angeles services homeless
authority. And county of Los
Angeles to reach this
population additional funds
could make this effort much
more effective. To support
these program areas we maintain
a website senses that alley
city dot org provide language
access in twelve non English
languages and support ADA
accessibility. The
infrastructure we've developed
and the partnerships we formed
over the last two and a half
years has made it possible for
us to create a multi pronged.
Multi faceted outreach strategy
which have shared with you
today. I look forward to
continuing to work with our
partners and with the state to
achieve a full count of our
residents. This concludes my
remarks I'm available to answer
any questions you may have
thank you. Thank you Mister
Jackson city Long Beach. Yes
good morning chairman number in
German pan in German Berman and
members of the committee- it
is- my honor distinct honor to
be able to present information
about how we're working toward
the successful senses here in
Long Beach in the city of Long
Beach- I wanna begin. My
testimony by providing some
background about how we're
working as a city in as a
community a collaborative
fashion to- manager which was
successful senses. Stern long
beach- we have undergone an
intensive- collaborative
planning process develop an
integrated strategic and
implement implementation plans
with members of our local
complete count committee. And
making sure- that our plans are
in alignment with the goals and
objectives of the federal state
and county partners- the
lobbies can completely out
committee. Is co chaired by the
city and the Long Beach unified
school district includes a
diverse cross section of local
leaders representing
educational institutions. All
of them here in Long Beach
hospitals and clinics-
committee of Bates Bates
organizations businesses and
our local transit. Health
workforce development agencies
are I'd like to point out that
over the past five months. The
goal of the- committee has been
to build effective partnership
in effect a partnership among
all our member organizations.
Are considering what each
organization I can do to build-
can contribute individually
while also capitalizing on the
synergy bring- caring leaders
together- in our community to
understand- the importance of a
collaborative effort. So one of
the first- and- I would think
when the most valuable-
accomplishments of our
community as we have worked
together collectively. Is to
the adoptee- guiding C. set of
guiding principles- to direct
our planning and outreach
efforts including commitments
to- want to count everyone to-
focus of course on- hard to
count communities. And nurture
a local- work force and finally
for to implement our plan our
plan strategically. Today I'd
like to just- share some brief
highlights- about the city's
plans and for census out reach
using these four guiding
principles. So to count
everyone I think our efforts
began with a commitment to-
holistic approach- in-
investing the necessary
resources to reach our entire
community. To that end in
addition to being the primary-
committed to being a primary
convener. Of over fifty
different organizations and
complete a locally based
complete count committee- we
have committed- five hundred
forty thousand dollars. Of from
our own general fund since
twenty eighteen and leveraging
obviously the- state funding an
amount of three hundred twenty
two thousand dollars-
subcontract with our partners
at LA county. The one of our
primary- activities to conduct
out reach to a variety of
communications. Media including
digital print radio and
television- as the main
commuter of the complete count
committee we have become the
center. Of the committee's
communication strategies. And
we are and that is working very
effectively force we're happy
about the progress that we're
making one that. A to be able
to support all of our partners
we're particularly proud of-
the outreach plants that have
been submitted and- are
actively under way with twenty
of our twenty three city
departments. We have stepped up
to offer their visibility
throughout the community-
interacting with the public. As
a platform for communicating
important messages about the
senses. The key highlights
include. Strong engages with
our city libraries parks
facilities in advance and
working with our public works
department- to brand
physicalist infrastructure
throughout the community.
Engage our utility departments
to send messages to our utility
bills. In addition- we're very
fortunate to have a partnership
with the Long Beach unified
school district- you'll hear
from. Later on a different
panel- it's providing us with a
unique opportunity for broad
based region gauge meant give
it C. Y. footprint. So to focus
in on hard to count populations
is the essential foundation of-
the city Andy committee
strategy for have a successful
census. And that that's it's
based on grassroots out reach
via trusted messengers and hard
to count- areas. As the primary
building block of our approach.
So we're working with-
committee based in faith based
organizations that provide
support and then- is part of
our- complete count committee.
And we're doing a number of
other things like- we are in
the process of developing
protocol for recruiting and
training- at least five high
volunteer investors who. In
other- active civic
organizations will be out in
the community of providing
information about the senses.
We've identified a hundred
twenty locations- process
actually he asked the question-
assistance centers
geographically concentrated. In
hard to count areas we also
are- taking steps to engage our
local ethnic media as a
foundational. Style element of
our approach- I want to point
out- that we are in a unique
position to be have one of our
three. Cities in California
have led to its own health
department so we are
leveraging- the capacity of our
health department through the
community services. To
relationships with our hard
account communities including
but not limited to strategic
planning of our language access
program. Comprehensive
engagement with our Housing
Authority tended in real
property or communities.
Engagement of our- early
childhood education partners
and- the Long Beach immigrant
rights coalition. Additionally
we're. Utilizing are we gonna
be level leveraging our-
homeless services
infrastructure to partner with
the census bureau to ensure an
effective- account of our
children and children homeless
population- we are really-
another a key aspect of our
strategy- where we've
identified activities. Is to
have neighborhood based-
community outreach and so we
have of the fortunate
opportunity to have. An alumni
network of seven fifty
neighborhood leaders who went
to our neighbor leadership
program. And we will be
reaching out to them to use
them as a foundation for-
building our neighborhood
outreach strategies. Hard to
calculus and beyond. On and I
just wanna quickly point out-
the third- principle that's
dried our efforts is to nurture
a- local searches work force-
couple things were doing their
our workforce development
agency here with the city
Pacific gateway workforce
investment- the workforce
investment network. Is a direct
actively- conducting our reach
the pools of potential census
workers- that process to
provide required skills- to
attain jobs with the senses
the- in addition they are
collaborating with the- Long
Beach complete count committee
members. Vertically committee
based organizations develop
shared messaging our
strategies. And we expect that
they will be co hosting
recruitment events at different
locations across the city.
We're working with the census
bureau- two provides the Philly
space- for training and
recruitment activities- and
then finally I like to. Just
highlight a couple things. At
the close about how we work is
strategically- we fully expect
that our committee- will be
using sort to identify
populations in locations for
rappers rapid deployment. Of
resources during issuers- and
non response follow periods.
And our model our collaborative
model has been centered around-
building a foundation to the
planning process but as we move
it to if you don't have time
will move it. To the taste
faced. A that we will continue
to bill. The capacities of all
our member organizations add
additional more member
organizations to assess-
without reach as we move
forward and collecting data and
analyze the data to sort we'll
be able to be strategic and
noble. To deploy resources were
needed throughout the effort-
and finally- we're proud of all
the work excellent let me what
we come back to a little later
during the- period we were
asking questions so. Already if
you want to just give us one
quick paragraph that be great.
I think- I think that about
sums it up for a you know
everything's going on Long
Beach I think- you know if I'm
if I could point out that. If
there are some strategic
opportunities for some
additional resources- we would
look forward to having- some
additional support for
technology Tallassee computers
to support our senses acting
kiosk. And a questionnaire
systems centers I in addition
to but potentially some
additional resources to support
support CBO out reach with
rapid response in Michael
targeting- it it it and
finally- communications-
support with- paid advertising.
At a high blood level here in
Long Beach thank you Sir. Our
next- miss Molly Nicholson of
public information officers
seat from. The representative
C. O. of county of orange thank
you he says because of. Good
afternoon center doesn't simply
members I'm all my name is
Molly Nicholson on public
information manager with the
county of orange first and
foremost I want to thank you
all for the opportunity dresses
committee and inform the public
of the census outreach efforts
in the county of orange. The
county released its request for
proposals looking and for trust
messengers provide census out
reach. In the form of
canvassing and other person
person strategies. The county
with the approval of our ad hoc
senses advisory committee
consisting of two members of
the borders of our board of
supervisors. They get a fifty
percent. Of our budget a two
grassroots efforts as it's been
identified as the most
effective strategy. To motivate
hard to count residents by the
California we count office and
various stakeholders. The board
of supervisors are expected to
consider these contracts at our
next board of supervisors
meeting. Should the board of
supervisors approved the
contracts for grassroots
advocacy efforts. County
stubble me with each contractor
to identify and schedule
outreach activities. Our
priority our priority with the
our grassroots advocacy vendors
is to ensure all resources are
deployed in hard account census
tracks and block groups.
Usually the county will be
placing a strong emphasis on
collaboration with other senses
partners across Orange County.
As a part of the county's
canvassing efforts are
contractors will be encouraging
hard account committee members
to participate in the census by
explaining the benefits to the
committee with messages that
are tailored and targeted to
encourage participation.
Contractors will be collecting
pledges raising awareness about
the resources such as question-
questionnaire assistance
centers and phone systems
language lines. The county will
be establishing question
question at assistance centers
in county facilities which will
include- C. public libraries
county warned social service
offices and family resource
centers as well as- as well as
creation of Q. a season non
county on sites. You a C. is
will serve as an important
purpose in creating greater
accessibility the centers will
make the census accessible to
all committee members welcome
Robert reminding residents of
the importance of competing in
the twenty twenty seven census
questionnaire. Using a
contracted media public work
using our contract the public
will public relations firm the
county will be crafting
regional messaging to
complement the state's
campaign. In addition to
building in unified messaging
and branding that will be
available to all partners the
county's public relations
vendor in conjunction with our
county seat your communications
department will help create
earned media efforts while
working with the outreach court
contractors to provide
coordinated media support. The
county's canvassing efforts.
The county is also courting
with terrible ventures of
Orange County and the C.
department- department of
education to ensure broader
collaboration- for census
offerts. These efforts have
been supported by the with the
leadership in input by-
congressman the crass offices
well senators on Tom Burke's
office we greatly appreciate
all the assistance from Orange
County delegations and in
regard to our efforts. The
county of orange will be
holding a coronation meeting
scheduled for early next year
early next year with all
contracted partners will be
working in region nine.
Additionally this group
identified the need to meet
more regularly beginning in
twenty twenty and found
opportunities to share
resources such as training
capabilities. The county warns
appreciates the funding from
the state of California and the
support of our congressional
state locations in order to
child achieve a complete count
in Orange County. Using the
funding provided by the state
legislature in conjunction with
the California complete count
office. The county will be
coordinating a multi pronged
effort to engage residents
through through in person
contacts digital and print
media. And trusted messengers
in a carefully coordinated
multi touch model that we
believe will motivate all hard
to count residents to complete.
Complete the twenty twenty
census. Again thank you for the
opportunity to look forward to
working with our partners to
ensure we have a successful
senses out reaching effort and
the virgin nine. Thank you
Mister Wilson- next miss daisy
press city of Santana. Good
afternoon senator Umberg and
committee members my name is
daisy Prez and I am the lead
for the census for the city of
Santana. The city of Santana
has the most hard to count
census tracts of all of Orange
County. As a result the city
has prioritized census outrage
as one of our major initiatives
for the twenty nineteen twenty
twenty fiscal year. In twenty
minutes early twenty nineteen
the city formed our own
complete count committee which
includes members of various
stakeholders. Including the
Santa Ana unified school
district Santa Ana college. And
nonprofit organizations that
have collaborated together on
these efforts. Are complete
count committee members came
together to create a
partnership video with trusted
voices from the city as well as
state and federal government.
Leaders that highlight the
importance of the twenty twenty
cents. We strategically played
the video to a captive audience
of over ten thousand residents
before the headliners
performance at our largest
community event of the year.
Yes the spot yes. At the same
community event members of the
Santa Ana complete count
committee participated in a
parade that had thousands of
spectators. Members of all ages
March down the streets of Santa
Ana and solidarity displaying
Santa Ana accounts and make it
count T. shirts down the route.
Since June city staff and
members of our complete count
committee have also conducted
out reach other countless
community events of all levels
including small scale
neighborhood events. To large
scale regional efforts. Since
June two thousand nineteen
we've anticipated we've already
reached sixty thousand members
of our community. Through the
leadership of the Santa Ana
city council the city has
stepped up and allocated our
own resources to fund these
efforts. To that end our city
council has allocated a hundred
and twenty five thousand
dollars from our general fund.
Towards this. This funding we
have developed a robust digital
marketing campaign as well as
funding for census ambassadors
and direct outreach. As a city
wide priority we have also
activated resources from other
departments to expand our
reach. One of those internal
partners is our library
department. In partnership with
the US census bureau and
library staff we are conducting
twelve informational workshops
in English Spanish Vietnamese
throughout the month of January
and February of next year. In
addition we have prioritized
our funding to help bridge the
digital divide by perching
purchasing additional wifi hot
spots that are available to be
checked out our library. We
hope that resources like this
will help families complete the
census from the comfort of
their home if they so choose.
Another key internal partner is
our water division. We're
working together in a joint
campaign titled make it count
to conduct additional outreach
efforts. With their support we
are not just adding census
messaging to our- water bills.
But we've also developed a
calendar that will be mailed
out to all households in the
city. And this will have
information on key dates from
the senses as well of as well
as other key information for
our city. And we're also
working with our- water
department and our economic
development division to conduct
direct outreach to our
restaurants and businesses-
they've developed several
materials for the children of
those restaurants. I was well
as for the general patrons as
well. Moving forward we're
going to continue to work with
our trusted- with our
stakeholders and trusted
partners to promote the
importance of the twenty twenty
census to ensure. That everyone
in Santa Anna's counted. One of
the city's biggest assets are
sixty four active neighborhood
associations and we will be
working with our local
neighborhood leaders to
conduct. Local outreach
throughout the next year. We
are planning to conduct a
series of community block
parties and community walks and
several of our her two count
communities in the city.
Through funding that we are
anticipating to receive from
the county of orange. However
we were recently notified that
we will no longer be receiving
this funding I will have to
significantly reduce our
outreach efforts alas
additional. Dollars are
received. Nonetheless we will
continue to prioritize the
twenty twenty census moving
forward. That concludes my
presentation and I am available
to answer any questions thank
you mistress of. Before I turn
it over to my colleagues for
their questions let me just
point out three areas I'm gonna
ask about giving up to think
about- while others are asking
their questions our first I'm
gonna ask each of you what
additional resources you may
have contributed to the effort
I a note this Long Beach and
Senate has already identified
some additional resources but-
like this east each of you.
What additional resources are
being contributed- what metrics
are performance measures you're
you're using so for example- I
recall that. Misa de ellos a
Garcia said that a goal of four
hundred goodwill ambassadors
you've exceeded- wondering what
other metrics each of you are
using performance measure
using. And then what challenges
what your greatest challenge.
May be separate apart from
funding. We assume that that
everyone needs additional
resources. And so let me. Turn
it over to assembly member
Berman since you're out
numbered four to one here I
thought maybe I didn't. That
opportunity to ask questions
they thank you senator Umberg
it's considered there twice as
many as family members and
senators- I commend the Senate.
On your participation in
today's hearing- and such
little we're always were much
more engaged in the assembly
it's a it's a you know I yeah I
can't I. Can't we care more I
can't argue with the obvious
okay are you there may there
are those right so- so couple
you mentioned that you're
hiring commuting back are not
hiring the recruiting volunteer
community ambassadors- to
participate- center Amberg
reference a second ago. Our I
guess the question is are any
of those ambassadors also
applying to be raiders or
helping in the Newman.
Recruitment could I know that's
an area that were falling short
across the state. Then and then
a lot. Of folks reference the
questionnaire assistance
centers. He asked and different
plans that you have an
identifying locations for those
how are those locations are
gonna be advertised to your
residence to make sure that
they know where they can go or
is the hope that they're just
so- you know it the spread out
everywhere that people are will
bump into them without even
meaning to- which would be a
good thing and I should say I
was really happy to hear a lot
about some of the- the kind of
PR efforts that folks are doing
whether it was garbage trucks
or- lampposts or other things
because my hope is that. You
know we count I count signs are
so ubiquitous across California
that everyone just feels like
it's something that everyone
else is doing and that there's
no risk to it so it sounds like
a lot of folks. Creative ideas
to make that happen. I can
answer the question I have for
LA county in regards to the
census action kiosk and kind of
how. How we plan to advertise
and- early on in the process
of. I. LA county with our
colleagues the valley we agreed
that we would develop a CAC
locator tool that would be able
to push out so that people can.
Find the closest Q. a C. will
also make sure that we provide
that information to our two one
one line we anticipate that
people are going to have
questions about the census and
I got a call two one one so we
have to. Make sure that they're
prepared- it also Ted make sure
that that line that assistance
is provided in language. It
also be something that we
according to our media campaign
but we did think about that we
did want to have one central
place where people can find
those. Locations red. And for
the city of Los Angeles. This
in terms of the ambassadors and
how. Are they learning about
the enumerator jobs that are
available with the US census
bureau. We have invited the US
census bureau to table at. All
of our senses a recruitment and
training events and if they
have gladly accepted each of
those opportunities- we also
provide the- opportunity to
make a page before and after
trainings. So they are well
integrated into our program. As
far as promoting this census
action kiosk located within the
city of Los Angeles we are in
addition to working with the
county of Los Angeles to.
Create the locator tool we're
also gonna be utilizing our
senses goodwill ambassadors
during the non response follow
up period and are canvassing
get out the count efforts. To
inform local residents about
the census action kiosks around
their neighborhood so that.
They know where to go where in.
If they do not have access to a
internet ready device either
computer tablet or phone. Or
just feel more comfortable
going to a location where they
might be able to obtain
language assistance or digital
literacy assistance. I and then
finally we're gonna be
incorporated senses. Kiosk
messages into our advertising
campaign so that they'll be the
messages where a we are
specifically promoting the
census action kiosks and how to
access the locator tool. So on
one beach we are also going to
be using- the locator tool-
we're going to for marketing or
chaos but in addition to that
incorporating information about
our kiosk in- all our multi
media outreach efforts-
digital- print- and so forth
but I think what's going to be
most effective for us in
marketing are and- our kiosk is
all the direct out reach with-
are masters- beat out in the
community. And hopefully our
neighborhood leaders- dispersed
throughout the city- that have
existing relationships with the
communities- that those- chaos
will be in I think the school
district is going to provide us
a really good opportunity- to
because they're contributing-
several of the- the kiosk to
their relationships to-
directly market those- the
kiosks in terms of. Promoting
the census jobs- we are
certainly- directing- that-
messaging towards our
ambassadors- and in a and then
also to- we're actually also
thinking about the idea of
providing that information to
our city employees who. Might
be looking for other
opportunities as well. So yeah.
Thanks. So the county of orange
is actually working- in
conjunction with the- US census
bureau in relation to working
to get enumerators so we've
been advertising in our county
publications your HR rep-
avenues some on Arlington pages
on all the social media outlets
to ensure that there is a good
deal of coverage in relation
that- obviously also made a
pitch to our county employees
or internal publication stern
sure there may be some part
time opportunities for them to
come in New as a numerators if
they have any colleagues or
friends are such that might be
looking for positions. So we
work very closely with our our
colleagues there as far as- the
queue a season such obviously
were were- curing up in
relation to that to actually
launch that into our family
resource centers are libraries
and such but there will be a
very much a big courted offered
once we do get off the ground
and get approval for our
grassroots efforts will be
working with our vendors to
actually launch that to make
sure we publicize and be
working very closely with the
CEO communication office my
office in particular. I'm sure
we have a great deal of
coverage as far as
communications concerned. The
bulk of the queue a season the
city of Santana will be placed
our community centers
throughout the city. As well as
additional- government
buildings we will be placing
this information and our
community resource guides and
recreation pressures that go
out- to all of our household
who'll be. Also placing this
information online- regarding
the census jobs and our
ambassador program so most of
our senses ambassadors are
actually our neighborhood
association leaders- and some
of those already have full time
jobs but we are inviting and we
have invited in the past the US
census bureau. I'm too common
table with us at events and
those have been very successful
thus far. Thank you. Thank you
seven member Berman center the
Russell. Thank you very much I
just want to follow up on the
issue of the hiring of
enumerators- it seems to me
there's some effort but I'm not
quite sure. How formal and how
big of a of an effort how big
of a push it is to use all of
our resources to make sure we
hire- that's what we referring
to right we say enumerators
they're the full time-
ambassadors are more the
volunteers. Right just just to
be clear on the on the terms so
just in terms of the LA county-
you mentioned- a little bit
about maybe using a human
resources but- is that possible
to use it in a much more
direct. All full way- the way
some of the other- departments
are being used I know
department social services I
think you- was mentioned that-
you can use the full scope of
the of the agency so can't you
made resources or maybe the
registrar of voters be used in
a much more forceful complete
way to find. Enumerator
enumerator applicants. And
overall just can we use. Of
current resources right now to
get the most number of
enumerators. So in my in my
remarks senator I mentioned
that- our county department
we'd axis currently
coordinating six events but
what I didn't say is then just
start in December it had
actually see I have previous
events to existing kind of
events we've been in including
census I. jobs messaging that's
part of it. The other part is
kind of making connections with
those applicants that come
through our county- either
contractors or through our
departments to make that
connection with jobs making
sure that we push those
messages out- another component
of that is also a media
strategy including our-
websites as well as pushing out
to social media. That's just a
piece or a component of it and
the other part that we're
asking our departments I had to
do was to come up with kind of
unique areas that we can push
it out whether it's through
partnerships with our cities
but also with our and with our
county departments. So it's not
just I know I mentioned the six
events happening but this I
want to make it clear that it's
been happening over the past
kind of. Six months. And do you
do you. Have any way of gauging
do we have. Sufficient are we
meeting some are there some the
goal. As far as the number to
be hired I know you don't do
the hiring but- I do you have
any way of gauging are we where
we need to be. In order to
reach. So many hard to count
Bob I think that's kind of the
difficulty for LA county is one
of the things that we're doing
and we have a meeting scheduled
with. The US census bureau to
kind of see how we could be
more helpful to kind of. Hit
those targets we know what
their goal is we know that
there are 30% of their hiring
goal. But I think that's kind
of where the partnership with
the US census bureau would come
in so that we can kind of.
Develop some metrics in each
of. The past. Okay yes and one
more question after you thank
you okay well I can I can offer
some comments about that- the
in order to recruitment we are-
specifically are having gazed
are- workforce development
agency Pacific gateway- to-
develop an excuse tragedies to
in partnership with the census
bureau- to help out with the
numerator recruitment we are
actively working with assisted
payroll to identify training
recruitment space in our city
facilities to host events- in
partnership with the bureau-
our workforce development
agencies acts is actively-
analyzing pools of existing-
job seekers- within their
current network- it for
potential- employer. Is between
toys for the senses that they
can actually train and referred
to the bureau for jobs. So that
is sort of the primary way that
we're doing our recruitment
for- at the numerators in the
city of Long Beach. It's one
more one more question is of we
all know that this environment-
that our immigrant communities
whether. Citizens or legal
residents run document doesn't
really matter you know our in
the- a- mixed emotions about
how to how much to trust
government- we had an issue
with our D. M. V. and the
sharing of information so. Can
you just tell me I know that's
not your sole responsibility we
have a media and
communications- part of the
strategy but how do you
especially Los Angeles county.
And Orange County how do you
sort of see our response or-
our communications are out
there to up to the issue of.
Immigration status- or our
communities to feel secure and
confident to up participate. I
can address this at least in
terms of addressing it when I
dressed our county departments
what I what I had text
expressed our county
departments is- the state of
California in LA county
specifically has shown to our
undocumented immigrant
populations that were there to
support them they've- we've
created the LA justice find out
in partnership with the city of
LA- additionally the board of
supervisors created the office
of immigrant affairs so I feel
even though we talk about trust
messengers often we're talking
about. CBO's I would argue that
and the county- it's also
county departments it's where
they go whether it's through
the library they take their
children there after it's our
health department so I think
we're cooperating a lot of that
message Jean and our touches-
and that is. Tied into our I.
county wide campaign the other
component for us- we also have
our office of M. good affairs
who who's kind of messaging
these to the various- CBO's
that we work with and also
that's what we're going to hear
from anyone if we start to kind
of hear misinformation they're
going to come to our office.
And I'm gonna fairs and
hopefully we can take that
message and work with our
partners whether it's with the
city or with C. CF to kind of
develop that and I think that's
where the collaborations gonna
be especially once we get to
the non response fallible be
hearing some of those things
and partner. From from the
community along as well as with
the state I think that's where
for us it's going to be key is
coordinating our messaging not
only with you know our cities
with C. CF as as well as the
states about world coordinate
in that regard. No just add on
the in the city of Los Angeles
in just reiterate as well. That
we recently held a briefing for
the consular corps in Los
Angeles- to brief them. On the
county wide efforts happening
here in Los Angeles and- get.
Their enlistment to help with
out reach especially with
nationals that go and seek
services. To their consulates-
directly. We're also. Working
with our senses goodwill
ambassadors and a- great many
deliver them- don't have
citizenship status and that's
because we've made. The
requirements to be a CGA very
flexible the only requirement.
Is to be. Los Angeles. To have
the event in the city of Los
Angeles and to be eighteen
years and older. So again
citizenship status or status in
the US is not a requirement to
be a census goodwill
ambassador- and we have been
able to do that- through the- a
private funds that we've
received through the
foundation. Out in also up to-
piggy back on the point of
young was making is that-
utilizing. Our infrastructure
both in the- county of Los
Angeles and in the city where
we have the mayor's office of
immigrant affairs. That works
directly with community based
organizations that service
immigrant populations. Out and
we've worked very closely with
some of the states a statewide
contracted partners like cheap
Lara. And the label to hold.
Out reach advanced to immigrant
communities to begin putting
out messaging. Around the
importance of participating in
being counted in the twenty
twenty census. Yes I'll I'll
just have to do our our
department of health office
equity- we do have strong
relationships with- the
immigrant and- and document
community- and particularly
with the Long Beach Long Beach
immigrant rights coalition- we
over the last- couple years
we've been actively working.
With those organizations- with
a couple outcomes with stops to
Long Beach justice fun. On the
Long Beach values axle the
strength of our relationship
with and the immigrant
community- are- are very very
good- another key indicator of
how we're working with our
immediate community. They are
actually a part of our complete
count committee and they- are
actively working with us M.
proposing activities to help
us. Get the trusted messages
out into the community- so we
have a really good opportunity
to our office equity and the
work we're doing with immigrant
relations. In an office. I mean
working for the government
obviously know that sometimes
people are are of little
hesitant to talk to county
governments are city
governments especially you know
with county governments you
deal with us on sometimes on
your worst days- but there's
also. You're dealing with a
summons up making great
relationships particular with
our family resource centers are
social workers and such along
those lines that are more of
our trusted messenger so we're
looking to leverage. Those
relationships that some of our
our constituents have with some
of our of our folks that are
actually in the community
helping provide services and
such. But the trusted messenger
component is very important as
well and we understand that
that's going to be the way that
way in- they how those
relationships there fomented
them over the years they've
there's now a trusted component
there. So we're very cognizant
of where our weaknesses are as
far as doing the outreach and
the and the communication would
differ constituencies. So the
county is working to leverage
all of our grassroots advocacy
components that are actually in
the community that are seen as
trusted messengers to help-
advocate and make sure that
these folks that are in those
hard account areas. Fill out
their census forms. The city of
Santana has identified this as
a tremendous challenge since
the beginning of our efforts.
As a sanctuary city we have a
century advisory round table-
that has come together. And we
are taking advantage of these
community partners- and there
were working with them and with
our Mexican consulate's office-
to come up with additional
messaging have a specifically
targeting- the myths regarding
the citizenship question. That
was up there because some folks
still think it's going to be on
there. And also just-
reiterating that their data
safe- as you mentioned the-
incident that happened with the
DMV didn't help our case- so
we're gonna all. Just continue
to move that message forward.
And we've been working with
staff from the county of orange
to come up with a joint- info
graphic on that we can display
throughout the entire county.
Just indicating what happens to
your data once you respond to
the census. And that they can
see that on this will not be
able to come back and be
tracked to them. We're hoping
that that will be helpful and
we'll have that in a series of
languages as well. Thank you
Senate also center pan. Thanks
very much us our number you
know I think all the presenters
I know that the amount of time
we give you. I was not in
that's really tough to. Cover
everything you're doing and-
so- but- I. Think the idea was
to get the highlights and
certainly any material can send
us about some other activities
is always welcome- first a
couple comments and then a
couple questions- so first of
all- children her when the
group's that's- hard to count-
some hoping that in the
messaging that's going out to
everyone I know people working
with we came from schools in
the first five and so forth.
But also just kind reminding
people that if there's children
household the need to count
them right now they need so.
Hopefully that's part of the
regular messaging and also
given some people. Some
guidance as to the house
basically just remember you
know you just you can yourself
but you also need to. There's
kids in the household sure you.
But the man they're all the
kids. Right the other thing is
I know that many of you
mentioned- you know you're safe
secure a season so for them
hoping that- the state folks
that we can actually- and you'd
mentioned you have a- locator.
App I'm hoping that were
everyone's entree develop their
own. Maybe we can the state
should do that and we have a
statewide database of all the
curious use and so forth so
anyone who's wherever they are
could actually. Intentionally
pull up and out and find it I
know many people use mobile in
people who do have access often
be. Particular income just need
to have mobile that honestly
have desktop or something so.
Again trying to be sure that
that that information's easily-
obtained in this M. the symbol.
A couple questions. First is
about language access- you'll
for the API community
particular but also for many
other communities language is
an issue. We know there's
several languages that are you
know in the part of the census
program and the senses of. I
guess what I'm asking and ask
about is the ones that aren't.
Right you know the ones that
are the top five or even the
top ten. Okay and we're talking
with the hard to count so- and-
so what is being done to reach
out to communities were
speaking. I would say fairly
rare languages okay. And trying
to figure out how do we get to
those communities- some of them
de languages may not
necessarily. Really have a
written form it's merely or all
other types of things so you're
not going to hit him in mass
media. They may not they may or
may not be in social media out
there or not going to be hit
but the- you know that they're
not want. Qualified census
languages. What are you doing
to try to help and they may not
necessarily. Cluster all in one
geographic area either to be
scattered. In you know and
obviously- L. A.'s certainly a
melting well the salad over
some feeling multi pot. Garden
salad of you know only rightly
cultures. So can Jean maybe
speak to particularly languages
that are. Fairly infrequent
that are not the main which is
are the top five that you're
what were you doing to reach.
Out to those communities and
provided language support.
Suffer the LA county most of
what we're you know we're
contracting two thirds of that
so we're working with the
cities to meet that but what we
looked at internally I mean one
of the reasons we have so many
Q. A. seizing and Q. eight
cases. We don't know if people
are gonna be driven there so
we're trying to cover all the
places that they potentially
will be. And to cover all those
languages like we're trying to
look where we have county staff
who speak that language for
example our department public
social service but there's a
big gap so one of the things
that we looked at is-
contracting with the language
line this is. A service that is
used in our health centers in
our public health centers to
offer that translation service
which would go beyond the
threshold languages. So that is
kind of a resource because for
us I think it's- in terms of
value in kind of the dollars
that we have limited. It is-
what we're looking for that's
kind of how the LA county is
going to be addressing it at
some of our Connie locations.
On the other thing I just
wanted to mention because we
talked about the CAC locator
tool. I did want to say
obviously our locations are
gonna be uploaded into sword so
that would be what information
if we're not going to just do
our own thing and then. I'm not
have that information available
statewide so I just wanted to
clarify that. The other thing
in and understanding that is
really important for us to go
where people are. Here at the
county what we're looking at is
also- developing mobile kiosk
where we would actually go J.
events so what we're doing
between January through the end
of the response rate or working
with all our county
departments. Our board office
is to identify kind of the
locations were hard. Counter.
Where do we already have. A
presence. And what can we go
to. Because I think that it's
going to be key. Is reaching
out to them where they're at
not necessarily hoping that we
drive them to our libraries are
drive into health clinics. The
idea is. When they're there. We
can make a contact engage maybe
engagement courage and Kerr Jim
to fill out the census that is
one way. Really we realize that
we have to also complement that
with going out to where they're
at. And for the city of Los
Angeles I think M. were really
taking this as part of a three
pronged strategy one. Is by-
this is where our partnership
with the Los Angeles regional
census table is really. Going
to be critical because- I will
be promoting all of the partner
hot lines that have- them in
operation during the-
activation period in making
sure that- if somebody needs to
be. Directed to a particular
language line where they do
have that language expertise
that we're promoting- that
hotline- we're also going to
be- including. The link which
guides that have been developed
by the US census bureau and
fifty nine different languages-
in our- questioner. In our
senses action kiosk locations
and providing them an outreach
events that we attend. There's
more to Steven languages in LA
right. Yes yes. I and then we
are also through our- senses
goodwill ambassadors programs
does since is good with a
masters that. Speak unique
languages- we're gonna be
tapping them to. Have them
lead- events where they are the
trusted messenger in about and
ambassador to their community-
to. Inform people of the twenty
twenty census in their language.
So we currently have a language
access program that provides
interpretation and- translation
services for- for any language-
if you will with the core.
Language is being- comite to
Golic- in Spanish- or the
principal languages- that are
of concern to our community.
The comite is of particular
concern to us- because is not
one of the primary our priority
languages. And Long Beach has a
significant Cambodian
population. So we are
prioritizing resources to make
sure that- we do you know
direct out reach out to that
segment of our community-
through ethnic media outlets we
have one here- and- working
with arc Cambodian community to
assist with. I think you. Just
doesn't brief follow up so you
could you a large committee
population in Long Beach. Is
obviously M. does other
Cambodia populations across the
state- is there any
conversation again we see
people haven't had a chance to
talk yet but- to take okay well
since. Long Beach has a large
committee population develop
materials whatever out reach
that that's that available to
other places that may not have
larger they have me a small.
Cambodian populations but may
not because they're smaller
don't have this many resources
to so like are we to exchanging
or trading information with
other. Places so I would
imagine Long Beach by take the
lead on the Cambodian
population. Yeah absolutely we
are certainly willing to do
that I'm not aware of any
contact that we've had with any
other communities in that
regard but however. On it's a
very good point- we were very
well resource that area and so
we would be willing to offer
our support okay what so that I
think that would be so
hopefully some there be a
conversation. About that
because at. In for example I
know that- some of the- of
Pacific Islander population I
guess represents what point 4%
I saw in the- thing- you know
like Samoan vis a fourth. Out
so who's gonna develop the
materials for that and do we
need every hello this every
single county develop their own
or can we find a way to. Where
there's local areas that may
have a larger community where
they may have be able to
because they have. Those
relationships than help use
those materials that can help
other places than say well we
don't have as much of a- you
know relationship or the
committee's much smaller
commuter area but then we have
materials we can use our our
our- you know. Advice they can
give to do that so hopefully
we're creating some sort of
learning collaborative or
something about that- for and
in in date. I believe in and
maybe the sticking cracked me
later that I think part of that
is Steve Craig partner portal
would be able to share some of
those materials that probably
would be a good resource for us
collectively. And share. The
material look at the same yes I
think the. That was the
intention of that I think. I
think you and I the deadline
the electorate's county yeah
colleagues as well thank you
senator pan- obviously at
working as a communicator in
the in the county of orange and
the need to have things
translated in multiple
languages or is incredibly
important- within the county
itself we obvious people of
speak Farsi Spiegel different
types of Chinese. Commands the
other one we do have a
Cambodian population as well so
we would love to have that
support we do have interpreters
are on staff whether they be
work for the social services
agency and have translation
components we have an outside
translating- service that we
actually have at the county-
the big the most important
thing for me is obvious I'm
getting it right and writing
but for people there on the
ground. That they have those
cultural norms cyclical
sensitivities to actually
communicate effectively is
gonna be the most important
thing so as you can imagine I
am not gonna be an expert on
understanding all the cultural
norms and subsidies ages
whatever whatever needs to
occur. But I want to insure as
as whatever documents we get
are are done correctly and-
looked over in message tested
and such on those lines so any
resources we have the hive mind
the that their communities and
such would be great as you can
imagine even the different-
constituencies across it. From
so as well so we would love to
have that support and we look
to see what we can do to ensure
that the messaging is done
effectively. The city of
Santana has access to
translation services in Spanish
and Vietnamese when we need
access to census material in
other languages. We have
reached out to our partners at
the county of orange- but it
that is for some of those
common languages like Chinese
husband really hopeful that
materials that we- receive from
them. In that language- but to
echo Molly's comment that would
be great if the state
prioritized. You know. Bob
putting out information that
any city or county could use-
in multiple language in that
way we can ensure that state
wide we have a clear and
consistent message. Okay no I
did have a second question boma
turned to a comments of a
question because I know we need
to move on up. The others that
I guess. Question or comment I
was gonna say is that. As we're
moving along. I just know how
organizations work in this
Friday also question of him for
the for are coming and give to
our non profits are presenting
next. Oftentimes is especially
with a deadline were barreling
along we need to get this done
we tend to go to our usual
partners. Right there the
people are used to working with
the people we have a
relationship with and that's
great and we need to work with
them- but I also- asset we also
especially since we saw several
few months hueso Hundred Days
to think about the people we
don't normally partner with are
the people who we have and
there might be different
reasons that might happen over
time or something- but- you
know. But they're also
representing groups of people
who then what happens may not
be as touched rate because
we're so. I just ask that we
reflect on the. If we just wait
for the people who were used to
coming and they come to the
table but we're not looking
like we're the empty seats are.
People having come to the table
so I think this is a good time
now the server reflected. Who
is it that's out there that's
not here. You might have had
even a bad experience with them
before this. You know let it
and say well. Do you need to
rethink that especially for the
census so I'm just gonna throw
that out there. I'm sure you're
doing all the out reach you
can- but I just want people to
think about that because those
are the places where gaps could
occur as well. And then it's
harder it takes more work
because these are people who
used. To you. You know all this
I have an existing relationship
with. Thank you. I'm thank you
Senate pan. And we ought to put
a- pin in it so to speak. M.
went when miss Katagiri
testifies will later on. That's
a great question about.
Coordination of resources you
know using the combined
language as a- an example there
other places and- in the states
and Hannah for example. That
has a large sum of my speakers
and so. We should be. Making
sure that we- have some
economies of scale here all
right. Before we turn to Senate
Gonzalez- and I know that the
every question that was asked.
Every member of the panel feels
an obligation to respond I
promise not to hold against you
if you don't need to respond to
every question- if you want to
contribute that's wonderful but
but you should not feel
compelled. To contribute on the
on each question and that will
apply to. Later panels as well.
RT senators aus. Thank you this
is been a great discussion so
far so thank you all again- so
again I a thinker reiterate a
lot of- what my colleagues to
talk about in terms of this
year to three population- and I
didn't see and maybe I. Just
skipped over this my head but
early education sites. Are we
thinking about a strategy to
tackle you know the
preschoolers. And also even I
was just at Saint Mary's- and
looking at the maternal sites
and- you know- Lumos classes or
is their strategy for that
because I think that's where
even if you're pregnant they're
still someone that's coming.
Along that sometimes often is
not counted mothers are not
thinking about counting them. I
can speak to that so I believe
it was. Maybe two weeks ago-
incarnation with. The LA county
office of education first five
we help her. Kind of first
convening of all the various
partners and I think those are
some of the strategies that
were- kind of. Included but
were supposed to have a follow
up meeting in January second
take some of those comments and
feedback to make sure that we
include those populations but-
what we did for this initial
meeting was for all these
groups to kind of get in a room
and share what they're doing
whether it's in the spree
schools whether it's in schools
are like- so that we had that.
One conversation so I can take
that back to our next meeting
which is scheduled for. January
no that our colleagues from on.
LA county office of education a
touch on that too but we will
take that back to make sure.
Great thank you and then the
only other question is- similar
to a doctor pan mentioned
about- people we don't often
think about collaborating with.
But I would even look at how we
can leverage private support
you know some of our larger
corporations. Both on the
funding side because they often
have social responsibility.
Opportunities where they can
give to the census- initiatives
and be. For their employees
that could potentially
volunteered become ambassadors-
so I think just things to think
about unless there's something
you want to highlight if we're
already. Working with some
private industry think that
could be another opportunity.
I'm at all just hi late as
something that we did- in
partnership with Wells Fargo we
trained their employees to be
senses goodwill ambassadors and
so- that's just one example of
how we are leveraging our-
partnerships. With private
business. Yes on. The business
local businesses a sector in
our complete count committee
and we've engaged a chamber
with engage- our business
improvement districts- but also
some local business businesses
as well- we have. A one example
of I like to share is frontier
communications. Is a city in
art- our complete count
committee and- they have-
offered up- an opportunity to
partner or one- trying to
access some equipment-
technology equipment. You know
it's so it may not meet all our
needs but we feel that that is
very substantial- on a
substantial contribution that
they're planning to make an-
and so. I felt was important
highlight that one in
particular. So and that's kind
of part of our model and how
we're working and that's why we
Gaines to businesses- to have
direct out reached with the
business but also to cultivate
opportunities for. Sharing
resources and so I want to lift
up that one example frontier
communications. Thank you
Senate themselves alright let
let's just do a quick lightning
round here the questions I
asked earlier Wilk will just
start with Mr Rebay- what what
is Los Angeles county if
anything contributed. Beyond
what state resource provided.
So some terms of resources- I
think when I started we had
maybe three or four staff I'm
just fully assigned to census
meaning. They were not given
any other responsibility I
think since I'm about to about
maybe seven staff including our
J. S. of separate this point
it's been staff resources. I do
think as we start to conduct
some of this gap analysis on to
the end of this month and we
bring our cities online at the
maybe. We may be looking at
potentially non response follow
up as kind of a an an issue
that we may have to kind of the
board resources but I don't
wanna it's not up to me but I
think just. In terms of kind of
what LA county has dedicated
terms of resources so is there
a specific. I'm actually
looking for specific dollar
amount is there's specific
dollar amount that the county
of Los Angeles is designated-
potentially yes potentially
tensely yes any sense of when
that might happen before April
I hope. Yes before okay because
I think I would like to come
back and provide that but I
think that the answer is yes. I
just don't have that the
dollar. All right city Los
Angeles. The city of Los
Angeles has contributed two
point one million dollars since
twenty seventeen. Thank you.
Long Beach. I know Mr Jackson
Yuri testified I think was five
and forty thousand dollars is
that right. Right all right
county of orange. I don't have
that figure but obviously can
get that to you but we do have
staff there obviously working
on this currently and also will
not be engaging our our staff
from different various
departments are twenty three
departments across the county.
Okay Senate I think you've
testified but go ahead. Yes so
this. City has allocated a
hundred twenty five thousand
dollars from our general fund.
In addition- our other
departments have put together
about fifty thousand dollars
towards this effort. And then
we've allocated about
700-007-5000 dollars so far and
staff time. So far the city has
put about two hundred fifty
thousand dollars towards the
suffer. Already thank you. Our
next question for the group
lightning round it metrics- if
you can. Give me just one
example of a metric that you're
using- pre April. That would be
helpful and then then to the
extent that you actually have
metrics- and where you are in
those metrics if you could
submit them to us I would be
interested in that so. Starting
with county. Was sentenced so
one example because it's fresh
in my mind as to our media
contractor we actually do have
kind of metrics for kind of how
we're spending those dollars
whether it's like click through
rate social media kind of.
Facebook I think those are
things that we bill ten because
we know that we're going to
have to kind of demonstrate our
dollars and how they're they're
effective so that's probably
one example but I can also
share other metrics that were
incorporating. Within our city
contracts including here with
city violated a really great
job of kind of Allen with their
metrics as well as long beach.
City Los Angeles. Out through
our out reach direct outreach
efforts were actually already
uploading information onto the
sword system that documents
number of impressions that we
are having out of all of our
outreach events- and- I already
mentioned the goal of
recruiting census goodwill
ambassadors we've exceeded that
and- I we will also be
collecting metrics from the C.
D. A.'s each one of them that
we train I will be expected to
collect twenty five played to
pledge to be counted- the and
cheats from the people that
they engage. And for the many
grants that we give that to you
organizations there- the goal
is to obtain fifty so I'm just
to the panels so what am I in a
they may have been articulate
when I say metrics actually
mean performance measures so we
set you know for example a goal
of four hundred and we have
achieved. X. towards so long
which. So we work with our
member of yeah organizations-
to identify activities- to
contribute to the towards
outreach effort- and they set
goals- in so we're gonna be
tracking those activities in
sort- to determine you know to
have an example of any of those
those goals and- where you
might be in relation to those
goals. We've we've just I. we
just completed the
identification for
implementation plan of those
activities and so- and we
created the tracking mechanism
now for sort. And so we haven't
begun putting that information
in the sort- we do have a goal
a couple things I can highlight
you know we have a goal to
recruit five hundred senses and
passengers- we know we're
starting with as a starting
point we're gonna be working
with our seven hundred fifty
neighbor leadership all. Alumni
we think we- will make us not
get halfway there so we we've
already begun working on that-
we can we reach out to our
board to commission so that
that's that's perfect that's
what I'm looking for is we have
a goal of. X. in we are keeping
track to see how close were
coming to that goal in our
progress yes. Alright I could
point out one other thing we
know that we have this the
bureau has a goal of hiring
four thousand- enumerators your
long beach. On the currently-
as we understand it we're at
about two thousand- and so we
have a delta there and so we
are using- our workforce
development agency and apart
all right right thank you
perfect okay. Connie Warren
should. We are currently are
working on the establishing
these goals and these metrics
in relation to a because
obviously the state would like
are why no one where that we
need to put resources as you
can imagine the communications
component. That'll be even more
easily trackable as far as
impressions of concern there's
no there's no performance
measures not this not the
present time rhetoric and
you're going to you're going to
help. Us out and absolutely all
right thank you Susanna. So one
of our goals is to- interact
with approximately three
hundred. Thousand residents
over the period of time. So far
we've- counted about sixty
thousand direct impressions.
And then we're also counting
how many sign ups we receive
from residents to actually
receive ongoing updates on the
census. So far we have over a
thousand emails and phone was
goal. Goal we don't have a
number set for that one we just
are trying to get as many as we
possibly can. Last lightning
round question- I I'll- I'm
sure you all need more
resources will will assume
that- but separate apart from
money what's your biggest
challenge. Besides time because
we don't get an extension for
the science right so well
except that I'm for LA county
at least I'm now that we have
the guidelines for Q. a season
sake he at. Our senses action
cast in the question arcs and
centers it'll be kind of
rolling that out to make sure
that the locations we
identified meet those
requirements so that is going
to be a significant challenge
so in light with the C. bill
they were going to be doing a
reading this assessment of our
county locations but for us-
that will be our Christmas. And
new year project can make sure
that our locations kind of meat
that the requirements. Thank
you said it was angel's direct
out reach to residents
experiencing homelessness given.
The size and complexity of our
population. Long Beach. Outside
of resources I would say
additional support- so much LA
reaching out to our homes
population. Well when Connie.
The challenge is obviously just
the number of the volume of
folks that we actually have to
touch within a relatively short
time period so probably the any
specific Orange County
challenged. None that I can
think of right original
Santana. One of our challenges
is to ensure that all of our
households within one address
are counted we have a lot of.
Other folks living and I AT use
or additional units within that
property and just combating not
just because- one of the
households in the- and not. For
the address was counted does
not mean that everyone in the
household with cabinet alright
folks that don't necessarily
feel that they're part of this
household. We just need to make
remind them that. They should
be conscious teller some of our
colleagues are trying to create
more eighties matter fact. So a
couple questions county of
orange- the- city of Santa said
that they're the hardest to
count. The city is that right
is that your estimation as
well. Yes the city's a Santana
as well as Anaheim would be the
two hardest mathcounts cities
in the in the county of orange.
All right in in terms of
coordination with the county
Orange County part of education
are you cordoning with the
orange Gaines particle of
education yes we are at this
time. Okay and maybe offline-
will last some more questions
about how that coordination is
going and what their plans are
as well. So all right- thank
you very much we appreciate
your time panel- will excuse
you and will call up the next
panel next panel is weak count
LA community our senses- and
that. Will consist of the
California community foundation
Ephron Escovedo. Vice president
Long Beach forward James water
so- associate director in south
east LA collaborative Cynthia
Cortez associate director. So
if you all come forward in in.
Before you testify. That we
appreciate that you probably
have much more to say the than
the time that is been
allocated- contrary to popular
perception all of us up here
can read so if there's if
there's something that you'd
like us to consider- please
feel free and I know I've asked
some questions asked for some
follow up information- please
consider giving us additional
information in writing and I'm
in also informed our staff can
read as well. Some all right so
let's let's start with. Efron
Escovedo from the California
community foundation thank you
Sir for being here. Thank you
senator Umberg and members of
the committee Senate member
Berman thank you for a-
representing the assembly in
the house sheet that. I'm well
the this morning I'd I'd like
to make some brief remarks and
an appreciate center that asos
point about- we all know the
census is important so we've
been on it for two years- but
where are we today on so that
we could understand what she
pouring going into twenty
twenty and- I'm privileged and
excited to share the stage
with. Two very important
partners of ours in in this
effort which is Long Beach
forward and Marcella
collaborative of folks who
really exemplified- the answer
to that question so be sure to
leave the time for them- in
terms of Los Angeles county do
have to say that where we're at
right now is a in our sense a
great spot and a lot of it is
because of what. You heard from
our leaders both at the county
and our various key cities it's
because of the trust and early
coordination that we've built
with the county city about laci
of Long Beach and other cities
that I'm we've really as
administrative CBO California
community foundation and our
partners have had an
opportunity to really free Lee
and deeply focus on what is our
community need to be sure we
have folks who can reach folks
out the door. To make sure that
we've identified brick and
mortars where the county can
partner- with folks to be
questionnaire assistance center
I'm and all of that knowing
that simultaneously the county
was working on mobilizing every
resource it had as well as the
city the city's contribution
into the port fun for Los
Angeles was a tremendous
catalyst in addition to the
states of funding to also bring
philanthropy to the table. So
what I will share with you
today that I'm. One the early
investment. From your
legislative Bob- the support of
the governor's office and the
everyday support of the of the
complete count office brought
significant resources to Ali
eight point four million but
what really has happened since
then is whether public sector
partners and community
partners. Really working with
philanthropy to have them step
up and I'm happy to report that
in addition to the eight point
four million investment from
the state we've actually
augmented dot to upwards of
over seventeen million dollars
that all have been concentrated
on get out the count efforts-
in various communities and hard
to count tracks in LA county.
The way that we've worked early
and planning has been in
collaboration with key
organizations that have been
transformative to LA on any
issue from healthcare to
education to civic
participation and what you see
up on the slide is what we call
the core of the steering
committee so everything that
you hear about today has been
built in collaboration and
partnership. With these
organizations and as with these
organizations have been able to
then work and interact with the
county as they've developed and
the city as they've developed
the complete count committees
all these organizations play
lead roles in their regions it
helping to support other local
complete come committees
proclaim abuse for out in in
the valley has helped San
Fernando build a complete
commit. To these the really the
organizations that have built
it the question of metrics has
been brought up you see USC
Dorrance F. and engage our Andy
have been working
collaboratively with
organizations across the county
to understand how are you
measuring success we need a big
sure that success it is a
percentage Bates a person
counted and so they're working
collectively with us with the
sporty in this eight to make
sure that we have metrics as we
start moving forward but
metrics that are real- and so
we're- excited to have those
partnerships as well. I'm. A
lot of the work that we've been
doing early on. We received
resources from the state in
here I will underscore. That
having had resources early. Has
made a big difference in and
you'll see this in the next
couple of slides the first is
we work collaboratively with
our community partners and
steering committee to identify
what are the capacities that
organizations say they need to
build in order to be. Effective
messengers on the census so we
identified messaging media
tearing digital training that's
key things organizations needed
beyond just bodies. And to date
we launched with our partners
at Fenton aid. Tool kit online
tool kit that organizations
where organizations can access
these resources get access to
trainings we've had over a
thousand folks axis these tool
kit so far- eight hundred and
thirty three different users
and- just even more downloads
than that and you'll see some
of that. As our partners have
deployed those different
assets. I'm communications
training was something critical
we're gonna need. A lot of
different trusted messengers
and in order their trusted- but
in order for them to have an
impact they need to be
effective as well. And so to
date we've- collaborated to put
together for different.
Communications trainings across
the county where we've had a
hundred and thirty two
different organizations
participate. Again this is done
in coordination with our
partners at the state. The
county and the city as well. Is
just an image of different
community partners- building
their capacity talking about
there was a lot of conversation
early on about message testing
and what are we learning from
focus groups. This is an image
of all of that testing being
put to use in our trusted
messengers and working and
preparing for how to not just
talk to the community but to
media. To make sure every
opportunity we get we get the
right message. I'm we shared
with with the committee a quick
snapshot M. report of the scale
of resources that have been
deployed so here in LA county
as of last week. We've been
able to provide grant funding
for get out the count
activities to a hundred
organizations across the county
totaling. Twelve point seven
million dollars in investments-
with a mix of both public
dollars in private dollars this
covers a range of tactics
everything from door to door.
To train the trainer to
implementing more effective-
digital media out reach an
obviously as well- preparing
for becoming a questionnaire
assistance center and other
ways to help and be part. Of
the effort. I'm I won't go into
these pieces but in the
materials we provided and happy
to answer questions about what
communities have been covered
what populations have been
covered. I we've been able to
document and share that in
center pan to your earlier
question about. Our region
language there's what will be
able to print and we're working
all across the different
partners. To do as much as we
can but as far as organizations
on the ground we recorded about
thirty seven different
languages covered through the
various partner so far in the
grant making and so that gives
us extensively more reach. Out
to what we're doing and we've
provided for transparency
purposes were all the
organizations so far that have
been funded so. Once again
wanna thank you all at the
state fair leadership the
partnership with the state
census office but more
importantly our local
leadership at the county and
the and the cities that allowed
us. To really build this M.
partnership. Thank you mistress
committal. Now the Long Beach
forward Mr Suazo. It's going to
take a moment to click through
there you go all right a good
morning good afternoon whatever
time it is- legislatures spent
this time there is never any
never enough time in the census
my name is James was on the
associate director at Long
Beach forward on the first off
I have to say hi mom because
she's watching the live stream
right now so- I am excited to
share a little bit about what
Long Beach for it is working on
as one of the regional
coconveners with Ellie regional
census table. And we can unless
it was K. and so on a little
bit about going off of what-
the faint talked about in terms
of our we were organizing in
thinking about scale because
when we think about the census
and what it takes to get a
complete count it's a question
of scale right on so for us in
our approach with LA county in
on one of the largest and
hardest account in the country
we know we have a- large task.
Ahead of us and our approach to
that first I'm actually off all
the nineteen with the LA
regional census table which
was- research we restructure
the beginning of the year. To
tell coconveners including Long
Beach. Which are the events
from project California hello
boys became a beautiful. On the
cell a collaborative Cynthia
we'll talk a little bit about
their work- Anil deli partners
for health- to really organize
and bring together community
based organizations- to learn
about the census help get
prepared. And really it's a
recognition that CBO's are
trusted messengers within the
community and to focus and
prioritize. Our efforts on hard
to count communities- our role
is not only just to reach out
to her to come communities but
more importantly what often
doesn't get looked up. Is to
validate all of the messages
that are already being put out
there by different levels of
government. By our local
municipalities- and to ensure
that that people understand-
about the safety and security
of the census. So one of the
efforts that have come out of
that collaboration and resource
sharing. Has been the week
count campaign which you've
seen- that lesson just logo I
introduce you now to the- I
think cooler Long Beach version
of the logo- I'm a little
biased. And but just to give
you an idea of what the scale
looks like right when we're
talking about a regional
approach. We're also oh my gosh
when. Okay we're also talking
about a regional approach- in
the sub regions right. Where we
have organizations within Long
Beach coming together and all
of these different
organizations- that you can see
listed on. Working on various
levels of census education and
not reached hardy count
entities. And what that
actually look has looked like
on. Has been different- as
we've been go as been rolling
out of. Coming month and I will
say for us our team- back in
our- in our community the
census is already here right
there's no it's coming it's
already here for us. The what
that's look. It's been
connection and bringing
organizations together. Has
allowed us to do more
relationship building not just
within organizations. And
within our ecosystem but also
across sectors. So been able to
leverage relationships with
anchor institutions such as
state Long Beach. Even working
with the city as well- but also
availability asset building and
how we can- bring in community.
To read account community
actually off thank you. The
that's something that we didn't
one of our early meetings we
had organizations come in
whether they were large
nonprofits or small grassroots
neighborhood groups saying.
Ever going to reach out to the
senior population for gonna
reach us the black population
we need people from those
communities to do that. And as
you all probably know that
requires a hefty amount of
resources to really support and
do that properly- and for us
it's really about doing
hitting. The ground running
with direct out reach so
whether that's a door knocking
phone banking. And actually
doing that to scale where we
can prioritize areas such in
Long Beach. Like a central west
in north Long Beach where you
have these concentrations. Of
hard account communities and
just the lastly underscore- but
if I. N. mentioned. All of
these efforts and everything
that you see in these photos of
folks coming together in doing
this work. Is long term
capacity building and I want to
emphasize that. This investment
in community based
organizations to do this work
is a long term investment and
the health of the communities.
Where so many other social
programs and economic
strategies that you all are
looking at is directly impacted
by this. So we're building a
long term strategy to really
engage people directly from the
community. And at the same time
engage people on the importance
of the census. Thank you. Thank
you Mr Swasawke. I thank you
also for making sure that the
streaming is most valuable so
we know we have at least one
viewer. We appreciate that mom
for. Tuning in that'll help our
metrics so. All right. Thank
you. This Cortez. Greetings
everybody- my name is Cindy and
I'm very happy to be here to
talk a little bit about the
work the seller collaborative
is doing in the southeast LA-
to share a little bit about the
collaborative we are network of
nonprofit organizations gather
to lead southeast Los Angeles
county. Into era vitality by
strengthening the seller
communities. Building
collective power. And
encouraging regional systemic
change. Now one of the first
things I want to. Talk about.
Is what did our twenty ten.
Census response your profile
look like. And this map- really
highlights the fact that our
region is considered very high
are. Has a very high or high
low response gore. And we also
know that this indicators
derived by the twelve variables
that inform the hard to count
index. So when we start talking
about what is it going to take
to actively reach. The nooks
and crannies of the not only
the different cities. But
unincorporated areas or
different spaces that are not
necessarily easy to reach by
virtue of our maybe street
infrastructure system. We have
learned that by being able
start these conversations early
on. Our region has a lot of
unique stake holders. That are
all committed for census
engagement out reach but at
various degrees. So looking up
this mat we know I want to
highlight limited English
proficiency. Foreign born
certified and being a renter or
living in a multi family units
address. Are going to be the
big variables that are
impacting the score. What we
also know that because it's
highly read. All of the twelve
are very active in this region
which- means we have to be very
proactive and how we're gonna
tackle this. To talk a little
bit about our Ellie are C. T.
space. We do convene a
significant amount of nonprofit
organizations C. Beals. In
southeast LA. But because of
the nature of our city
boundaries the nature of where
our non profits are located.
And just because we're really
trying to convince the region
we also have the deferments
apologies. Folks such as gait
Kommersant or what these are
different folks that joined the
space to talk about their own
sense of. Outreach activities
in a into the work the C. B.
older. Doing that include train
the trainer models from but I
training campaigns- youth
ambassador work on mobile. Ask
unit. So what we're what we're
coming to this table and
everybody gets the opportunity
to report out in the regional
discussion component. That
means are also able to usher in
a conversation on the gap
analysis. So while we know what
I may be doing for hard to
count and my are restrictive
and what geographic area I want
to reach. When you're listening
to this fire thirty to forty to
fifty different voices we can
still build a common
understanding of what are the
additional efforts or the
partners we need to engage
with. To make sure that as you
move towards March we are not
only well prepared with census
knowledge but we're well
informed on a regional
strategy. So a lot of the work
that we're doing is holding the
space so that we understand the
roles. Of not only the C. deals
are meant to support partners.
And different key players that
I want to highlight to you.
Which include- how do we
continue to engage our non CEO
community star grassroots
organizations and volunteer
groups. That are highly
motivated because at the end of
the day they do know that
these- these funding resources
impact their daily lives. But
how do we get them the
resources. In a timely manner
and in a very accessible way.
We also recognize that for the
southeast region our faith
based organizations are another
additional trusted messenger.
We know that our schools are
trusted messenger so what does
it mean to make sure that they
are also in a timely manner.
Having the conversations
building that awareness to feel
very comfortable when perhaps
on delivering a sermon. Or
whatever out reach strategy
they elect into. The last
piece- because of the
coordinating component worth
trying to figure out are we
collaborate in a record eight
are cross promoting.
Understanding which later of
pollution our blossoming in do.
How do we as a collaborative
hold that space. To connect
people with the right agencies
are the right place are they
have a question. About cats
were connected them with the
city of a late work. Away or if
their partner that's active in
Long Beach making sure that
they are connected with chains
are partners in- San Fran Alex
on and so. Forth that's a
little bit about what I wanted
to share with you all to. Thank
you Cortez. I'm let's and the
comments and questions with
Senate pan. Thank you thank you
so much your presentations on
the work you're doing and I
appreciate the fact that does
recognize that the census at
work. Really is going on right
now right I mean we start
counting in April but the- the
US is saying the social norms
and building those
relationships that well Bob for
us in case people you know
others counter messages may
happen later on and so forth.
In and I appreciate that- that
actually that this contest
touched on this a. When we look
at the census. You know.
Everything's divide by
geography with census tracks
isn't it you know we- cities
and counties the odd boundaries
and so forth. But for some
communities right I mean- the
community isn't. A geographic
what it's not the idiom maybe
there's they may be in certain
areas more than others but
they're surrounds spread out
and I. Without actually
interest of the sets of data
will help us understand that
right so. The ability of GTP
community right Tom. API
committees are de maybe some
places they concentrate but
they're also spread out. So
when we're trying to figure out
how to message. Right in of so
I actually heard this from
somebody who said well. What
was with the senses budget very
geographic based right. And
that that's not really working
for my community because we're
not all one's face were kind of
scattered around so what are
you doing to be sure as were
touching communities and we are
you know I mean census
enumerators people point to
geographies but- that were-
crosscutting vertically for you
know of smaller communities are
two meters that are less
visible- how but in terms of
reaching out to people that
isn't just geography based but-
they'll they share a C. sure
Sir. Culture or other L.
characteristics are challenges
in terms of you know fear of
discrimination- they've C.
thing. But they're more spread
out. Can you maybe speak to
that what kind of work that the
hi how are you trying to bridge
that. So I'll I'll briefly
sharing try to. Take us back to
one Klay side just for
illustration to my comment I
think that's that's a very
critical point in and a lot of
the convening has been
geographic but when we talk
about really penetrating
community and doing work the
first step was first even with
geography usually folks want to
have meetings in downtown.
Where four thousand square mile
county and not everybody
identifies as Los Angeles and
so the idea that James shared
about regional lies in the
efforts so that communities
could gather more locally
around the region they at least
identify with was a way to get
more local. I'm they're still
be on that to your to your
point which is which is spot on
our other communities other
identities that that clustering
do if you look at some of our
graph you see that up Holly
county has the largest native
American- population in the
country but you wouldn't guess
that because there's not a city
that's majority native
American. But yet we have court
partners that we funded LGBTQ
community so the funding spread
out we convene a lot generally
I think there are he Peter ship
folks African American
communities is not south LA
it's up in antelope valley it's
dispersed across into Pomona in
other areas and so we have key
organizations doing that work
it's just not convene than a
geography but- yes and part of
our strategy as you see in the
graph is making sure we cover
that. The other thing I would
add to that question. Is really
important and I think when we
dive into the complexity of how
we're approaching. You know
thinking about what is the what
is the strategy look like on
the geography Bates versus
population base right. There it
comes down to a matter of
tactics to write when we think
about our door knocking
strategies in as work. On
designing where are the areas
were targeting in terms of
certain neighborhoods that's
great for specific card account
areas and the reality at least
for Long Beach. Is that you
have very dense areas that are
hard to reach where it's a
multitude of different hard to
come populations right so we're
talking about engaging partners
like the United can putting
community interface commute
organization. What we could
have teams of canvassers who
speak Spanish and come I.
because we don't know what's
gonna happen at the doors
right. But on the other level
there's also this- as a frame
mentioned relying on
organizations that can reach
popular in based hard account
communities right. To rely on
kind of a network model where
gauging organizations that.
Bill Ted of deep. Membership
and a base to really use that
and encourage folks to reach
out to the networks as well so.
Part of that challenge of
convene is trying to these two
the space for the second time
but- does that. This is the
developing now to take into
consideration. Ins. One thing I
really appreciate appreciate
about the framework of hard to
count or geographic reach or
tactic is out when were able to
talk about what area we may be
focusing in on the tape im
reaching hard to count
population Latino Spanish
speaking but somebody else's
reaching- the Hindu population
they know that a seller region
and we can cover the map an old
Spanish will do a good go far
but when it comes to like other
language pockets they also are
tapping into physically what
our locations folks are coming
together at so that you can do
if- physical- visible touch
point with them- another. Is
that when they're moving
through geography maybe the C.
the banner or the C. I hear
about a training happening it's
how many times do we need to
reinforce the message so that
the goal is that they behave in
a way that they fill out the
form not only I know about this
and but I'm not too sure if I'm
gonna do it so we have to
combine they have to C.
consistently as it of the but
they wake up to falling asleep
when they're on social media
opening up emails visually has
to be a camp. I could be
physically and argue-
neighborhoods but also in the
difference is they engage with
are people talking about it so
combining it is- our way of
kind of understanding that we
need to get this message out
there at least. Ten fifteen
twenty times before I guess
gonna do it. Tell. Is known for
competing at hard to count
population were are on a G. two
Q. presents meeting or if
you're up agency that have
multiple sites are all of your
sites echoing the same thing
the become something-
understood by everybody with
thank you so much and the those
were trying figure out to that
region appreciate that you
recognize this issue- and then
I know you're in the room when
a person to the other question
then I can pose a question
again as a comment you know
this by the time this before
you really get in bill for the
new year starts is. Sir
thinking about I'm sure you've
done this and you have a lot of
different but- the end just
think about. Are there gaps
there because of that- so
appreciate that. You would say
something about that. Yeah I
just I just want to add to I
think that like one of the
things that we've talked about
that we really- release all.
And the coconveners a we've
admired about the approach that
the California community
foundation is taken. Is when we
think traditionally and talking
about. How we're engaging CBO's
with to do census out reach we
think of the organizations that
how honestly a lot were listed
in the steering committee right
these. Large organizations that
have capacity right and the
skills to do this. One of the-
because we understand the
importance of what's at stake
in the census count. There are
regional approach and sub
regional approach has allowed
us to really engage. The small
grassroots organizations that
may not even have staff but
they know people in the
neighborhoods they can hold
those block parties. We have
around the fiestas coming up in
December right we could
actually engage people from the
community. And engage in that
type of strategy and allow-
resources to share resources.
To allow them to participate
and get rid of some of those.
Years so that's that's so
important and I just want to
split that up to emphasize. The
you raised. I appreciate that
is someone who I'd like to see
if he teaches asset base me the
valve and we talk about the
power of association C. on the
informal networks. And write
it. Because they made many I'll
have stepped. Informal right
and so oftentimes they're not
engage because they- had. Three
other types of things but- we
need for you how to reach out
to them because they can. They
can help out thank you. Thank
you Senate pan Senate and house.
Yes I think all my questions
have been answered this is just
more of a comment I'm really
blessed to have both of these-
incredible of people in my
district in Senate district
thirty three both Cynthia and
James and F. I. N. thank you so
much for work as well as doctor
Wilma Franco I know she's here
as well and- I just wanna say
on behalf of our residents were
really proud because we know
that we have a lot of work to
do- in the district that is
going to be. One of the most
affected so thank you all for
your work very much. In the new
wallpaper. Plenty of signs that
you can. And I have signed for
everyone so they're they're
also. Yes also thank you all
very much I know it's just
Cannella another's have been
working on this for a few years
and trying to put together way
in advance the sort of the
structure of the organizing of
organizers and organizations
one thing and I plan to ask
also on the state level that is
visibly missing very much and
he would be a shame to be left
out. Is labor. Organized labor
obviously has resources
organize and I don't mean just
like dollars the resources as
far as an organization many
organizations- they tend to
have a high rate of activism
they tend to have a high rate
of- turnout with union members
because they're engaged with an
organization as you find with
other the group so I'm curious
to see at your level- the
regional level- why that
appears to be missing. It may
not but it appears to be
missing. So I appreciate that I
think that. Definitely one
thing that's been cut-
communication has been there at
a larger the alley census
regional table does meet at a
macro level so there's the
regional meetings and a pipe
into a larger median I know
that they frequently-
participate in that the what
you're seeing on the region
always really the community led
part I think we could do more.
I'm I think that- having
leadership now at- complete
count committee level- with SCA
use presence there and in on
mas apiece could really be
helpful in that I'm I know that
in our Leyva we had initial
coordinating and- ordaining
conversations with with the
Allen county federation of
labor who was very helpful
they've been. Participants
throughout I think it's not
reflected here in terms of
who's been funded or not and
who are the- leads convening
but I think at this very stage
to center pants point about
who's missing. As we really
hear the starting gun go off
it'll be key. I will say both-
the county and the city through
the complete count- local
complete count have also been
engaging in making sure to
communicate with labor as well.
But I think there's- one more
integration level needed to
drop down and I'm I'm glad that
you raise that. Brought that up.
I just add because there's
they're in. Anyway I just I
just hope with de LA federation
that they're formally
broadband- so many different
unions so many different
geographical area so much of
the geographical area. And I
think if we don't do it early
it's a really really missed-
very big missed opportunity.
And I will share that I'm they
I have shared weather at the
tables are as we've met with
them- that they were working on
plans and we're doing that but
I think now's the time to now
bring them all together. Mr
squeal it is there a simple way
of describing. How all of the
efforts are being coordinated-
I know you that was a big part
of the presentation I so you
give a body your sole goal.
This so many efforts there's
the city's there's the counties
there's a school districts
there's community based groups
there's always organized by one
alliance and there's the state
effort. Is there a simple way
of describing this or is it
just is so much out there that
we ought to be glad there's
different groups yes it's the
state gives us the money not to
Skinner. I'm it I've I it it is
and one is you do see a lot of
different tables but what has
been clearly defined among all
of us in the partners. Are very
early on was what will the
county in the city's focus on
and we see and participate and
support that. What will- the
steering committee- with the
support of C. C. F. focus on
which was on the ground the
CBO's we will we will see that
so the county the city's went
out there actively. Trying to
grant or fund philanthropy said
the ACBL structures what the
what the state put in place we
will then pull all our money so
that we're not having
organizations right seven
different proposals whether our
own. Way of talking about the
census and so. The simple way
is we all identified the lanes
needed and everybody trusted
each other to run those lanes
and today as you see the
different presentations. We
kind of each are talking about
our lanes but we all
communicate and coordinate. It
looks. Eight I'm- it does
though however look messy. And
so. But it's working because
everybody has their lanes and
we're doing. Thank you senator
also seven number Berman. Quick
question for a friend you
mentioned that that LA- has had
a lot of state support also a
lot of philanthropic support in
is in a pretty good place-
right now- at this stage of the
game are there things that.
This region can share with
other regions of the state that
maybe don't have the resources
the for the private sector
resources- and maybe didn't get
us started as earlier as you
all have is there any sort of
mechanism for sharing kind of
best practices with some of the
other regions of the state I
know that you've got to focus
on on. The artist account
county but- yeah what any any
efforts are appreciated by some
others that are maybe a little
further behind. Absolutely so
first off say I think we have
had the states that Bob and
philanthropy step up as well
but I will be honest that a
hundred organizations- is a lot
but it's also not did what what
we have funded so far in the
twelve million is a little bit
less than half of what
different organizations stepped
up to offer but I think we're
in a good place and then we
were in any other time to meet
this challenge. To your
question about sharing best
practices one is every asset
that we we're developing is
open and shareable with folks-
the state has been working on
sharing and communicating some
of what we're doing but were
also now- working with them and
thinking about how do we do
that more formally maybe right
before- we pass the starting
line- but yes any asset that's
being developed we're- ready
and- eager to say. You know
this website that we created
for C. B. O.'s all that content
can be. Strip use an and a
white labeled perfect. Vision I
think on that note to I just
want to add to that when we
think about. For us to think
about like LA county as a whole
right again the question of
scale. It's been a really great
I like I often refer to it as
like a an interesting social
experiment like from that kind
of level to think about. Us as
organizations is coconveners
because the landscape in Long
Beach is similar yet different
than Stella and it's very
different from antelope valley
right and- so many other
valleys I live in Long Beach I
don't go to the other ballots
but- are. Able our ability to
come together and share how
we're organizing approaching
the region's has informed so
many other strategies of how
we're being more cohesive as a
region Allen. And I think
there's been no other
opportunities where each of us
have been asked in and are
willing to share with other
folks across the state in terms
of how we're approaching and-
trying to understand what this
reasonable containing looks
like but also. What are what
are these Beth strategies. For
a reason sharing and
collaborating bring photo the
other two. And one thing I
would add is I beat by virtue
of the senses we've I've been
able to expand our network. So
now becomes okay no- based off
of the list provided by C. C.
F. you're- being funded to do
this work I want to meet you.
What is your work look like
what is your general day to day
look like. And that allows us
to buttock our capacity to be
connected. So being able to
build those relationships and
not only share our
understanding and strategies
with the senses. Allows us to
think differently about
coronation critical ask each
other. What band with the you
have aren't what resources can
you offer what made you not be
able to do but how do you want
to be engaged so it's- opening
up those dialogue that are
critical and to move closer.
Towards April. Thank you. All
right thank you soon member
vermin. Couple questions let me
direct my question to you
Mister Sebadoh and the other
two of you can chime in when
you think he's wrong. So Bob.
That's gonna be often so it in.
In in Orange County terrible
ventures it actually they
engage in their own. Activity
to raise additional psalms are
are you any of you engage in
that activity. No not from
filled philanthropic sources
yeah cat California community
foundation as a committee
foundation we we're Los Angeles
county focus so we I. play
space. In the past and
historically we have been a
resource and a partner to
Orange County community
foundation sore level of
engagement has been through any
communication and coordination
with them as sort no I mean are
you seeking sources from for
example foundations. Themselves
to augment your efforts. We did
and we received I'm little bit
over I think we got up to
seventeen point four million-
so about ten million. Or twelve
million in philanthropic
resources okay city the end is
that part of your mission to
reach out. What we said we set
a goal early on working with
the stern command and our
partners of what would be what
we need are the real need was
identified at forty million we
said. Let's start at twenty and
so twenty has been our goal and
that's what we've been gates
the state on the city of al a
the county and then
philanthropy that stepped up
with additional dollars. Let me
ask you Jim who's your boss
mistress Camilla. With my boss
yes. The community of Los
Angeles but is there any one
individual you view is your
boss. The report any one
individual until now Hernandez
the president of our California
coming from all right Sir
source of. It was my boss yes.
My boss is Christine Pettitte-
executive director all right
scores as. Orally doctor Wilma
Franco and the communities we
serve. Okay I'm in in do you
report to- California of the
complete count committee your
complete count California. We
report- and collaborate
directly with the state census
complete count office I'm and
that's who we work with
directly on a day to day and
report on our contract activity
and what we're doing on the
ground with the resources okay
and then same question I asked
the previous panel in terms of
metrics one do you have
performance measures. And to if
you just give an example of one
of your performance measures-
sometimes referred to as
metrics. Yes we will have a
range of metrics in different
areas so and I'll be on a our
partner at the county shared a
little bit about the media
Metrix so those are M. we sure
communicated in and shared a
number of those with the state
there are all give you an
example- one M. one metric for
us was. Funding at least one
hundred organizations to do get
out the count efforts and so
we've reached that now begins
the work with US C. of-
establishing metrics around how
many people were contacted
through these various
activities many facilities.
Were serving ask questioners
and centers on a media side how
much digital- reach that we
have and if we have media
partners out what what was the
measurable the fact that I'm
and so we're working to
establish those because we have
the metrics what we're working
with the state on and have had
a lot of great support from the
sort D. this how we collect.
Those metrics. What is this so.
Form is bitter our performance
measures we want to fund a
hundred different. Entities
right in then. The metric would
be how are you doing in terms
of fun so you've you've met
that but how are you doing in
so in other places do you have
and I'm gonna ask each of you
and an example of a performance
measure- and how you're-
assessing whether you're
meeting that performance
measure. So I would say a bomb.
Yes and to keep but the example
of the hundred organizations-
up on the screen you see. We
have performance measures
working with the our community
partners we sat what are the
important- tactics on get up
the count. That we need to move
our heart to count communities
and we have been measuring
ourselves by how well have we
done. In supporting each of the
key tactics so up on the screen
you see these little icon
infographics. Back that gives
you broken down. For the
organizations we funded how
many covered the top eight
tactics that have been
identified as effective for her
to count so that's I think a
concrete example. Of how we're
measuring our progress so far
and right now it's been on
getting resources out and
making sure it's to the right
things and in the right places.
Long Beach forward. Terms of
performance measures first some
of our performance met- a lot
of it met- sits on direct
outreach efforts and measuring
the strength of our
collaboration so for instance.
On the direct out reach peace-
part of our role as language
Ford in each of our different
organizations that have gotten
grants from- CCF which is the
combination of funds. There are
things like fifty thousand
hours of direct outreach
whether that's phone banking
whether that's a door knocking
to different hard to count
communities that are identified
gaps. Based off was being
funded- who's doing what so not
only is it looking at the
people who are already at the
table but what are the gaps
that are identified. And other
other organizations that are
trust the messenger G.
performance measures fifty
thousand. Hours in and how are
you doing on that. Are we
haven't started that we're in
the process of hiring people so
that way Connie January we can
start talking- so the other
other isn't examples would be.
A number of community events so
instead our organizations that
use all logos for earlier we
have a metric- bill mean.
January and July meeting. On a
monthly basis that's right.
Fact in a is. Because people
want to meet more often than
just once a month to. Get a
handle on all the coordination
and even things like of the
community events not just
direct out reach in the
community like a fiesta or
gathering. But also for
stakeholders one of our metrics
was organizing a- stakeholder
meeting for decision makers
that long which forwarded. Two
months ago and we brought
together representatives from
your respective offices from
the city from education to talk
about what organizations are
doing C. this group does. So
one of the ways we're looking
at data situating it back on
the twenty ten Allora scores
were one of them is- engage
fifty nonprofit organizations
in census our reach that allows
us to look at submatrix we're
looking at well to what extent
are folks using our senses
event calendar put on by the
seller collaborative we can
look at the back and metrics on
how many people are using the
website do they sell for port
value added are they able to
coordinate with different- did
you set a- goal for how many
people are looking at the
website. Not a goal with that
because it's such a it's in its
pilot phase you want to get at
least two three months of data
and to set that baseline and
then start to analyze what
would be a reasonable goal and
mobilize towards it so some of
the things are newer but for us
we felt that the fifty C. Beals
is reasonable our network
provides twelve already and M.
moving through the Ellie are C.
T. convening than just seen at
the different fine and she's an
who's represented a who's not
there we believe that fifty is
gonna allow was the range we
need- across the three
categories of out reach. And
parts come population
geographic so that not gold has
allowed us to have
conversations to develop some
goals like all the ten cities
and to incorporate areas
actually being reached so it's
a good anchor for us but we're
also committed to learning
feedback loop process to in
this complete cal California or
they enquiring as to your
metrics your performance
measures and whether you're
meeting them or not. Sorry KP
so complete cal California
that's the over arching
organization as I understand it
or are they enquiring as to
whether you're setting
performance measures whether
you're you know setting of
you're creating metrics that
kind of thing yes we've worked
collaboratively with them as
we've developed our
implementation plan and I've
submitted our reports on the
progress of that we've also had
meetings with the sword team-
to start thinking about how
will you be collecting those
metrics what support do you
need from the state- without so
we have been to some. Thank I
think that- part of what our
conversations are as far as-
how many people do you think.
That you can reach were at a
stage where. We don't want to
limit ourselves and say we
should Pat ourselves on the
back of we reach a million
people because- the charge
given to us by you all and the
state was. Get everyone counted
and so- as far as metrics
though the state has been very
supportive and we've been
reporting. On going and they
give us feedback and share
their expectations with and I
realize it's hard you know so
for exams some things are are
quantifiable number of a
numerators that you've hired
number of click whatever it may
be. It's much more challenging
in this operation one because
the time spent but also because
of the more amorphous nature.
Business you say they are
revenue goal is you know a
hundred dollars and we're at
ninety so. We need to earn
another ten dollars much
easier- okay biggest challenges
is. Briefly other than money
what's your biggest challenges.
Each of you. Biggest single
challenge. Other than the size
of the county in the two
thousand right hard to counts
tracks I'm I think I'm gonna
mention this it's really time
and it's not this is not some
amorphous challenge it's real
it's taking every day I would
have to say that the biggest
challenge for us right now is
organization to starting to
deploy their folks is just the
continuous guidelines that the
census puts out we're beginning
to feel like I'm it's really
discouraging to wanting to talk
to someone about the senses of
the federal or the federal
census has put out several
guidelines that. Use words like
it's federally prohibited to
contact someone or talk to them
about certain things you can't
make phone calls to people I'm
we continue to use our own
discretion on that but I think
the biggest challenges just
kind of the bureau start a
focus on regulating how
communities can talk to each
other about the senses- that
were concerned would be- a
challenge moving forward and I
think the other one which the
state- legislature and governor
are going to have been so right
in doing this was the passage
of a B. fifteen sixty three. By
assembly member Miguel Santana
go and- Gonzalez around
creating a census bill of
rights in California to make
sure. That some. Power for into
T. like our state government is
insuring are Californians that
they do have rights and who can
and can't participate I think.
On that will be very helpful to
meet those challenges well most
that's most useful if you can.
Provide us the specific
challenges that are being posed
by the federal government that
will help us because Anderson
pan will get resolved so right.
Yes and he will it. Right in
terms of singular challenge I
think going back to this idea
of scale but also what senator
that also brought up around how
do we need lead talk about
what's going on. We just can't
and I think what what has
happened- because of the
efforts of C. C. F. and all of
our convening organizations
with the we count campaign. Is
that the CBO- effort to reach
hard account communities is
very well organized. But and I
can't say that for all of the
other sectors where they have
that hasn't been years of this
kind of planning. And what we
struggle with is trying to in
good faith think about how do
we collaborate and connect with
other local levels of
government anchor institutions
are education healthcare labor
right all of these other.
Sectors that just aren't in the
same place where we are at and
our terms of our efforts in
outreach and recognizing that
partnership moves at the speed
of trust. And for some of these
institutions and its particular
with our organizations that
just isn't there and
unfortunately we don't have
time to build that trust so
it's really relying on- people
within different institutions.
To put a lot of trust up front
and I'm thankful for
individuals like Julian so new
that Kevin Jackson here in the
city of Long Beach of
understood that. To really
think about how do we start
breaking down these barriers
thanks. This contest. I think
it's been able to expand a who
are partners are. One example
in cell is going to be our
parent volunteer groups. So
while we know that the
different institutions like L.
USY are preparing to support
those parents. When we talk to
them on the ground the C. we
really want to have coffee and
census talks conscience senses
has been one of the things they
brought to the table. But we
know that also takes some
resources that maybe take some
trainings for them. So as we
think about- what are the best
ways to engage particularly
those parents groups. On one of
the things that we were really
excited about and I'm going to
follow up with our full. Our
friends at the city and the
county. Ellie city in the
goodwill ambassador program not
only was able to provide a
volunteer Steven for folks
getting trained. But is also
offering a mini grant to hold
an event in your community. So
when we hear about things like
that in the southeast we want
to be able to- learn how to
replicate that because that's
what we're hearing. From our
parents from our cousins from
our youth. I think all we want
to get active to but what is
the right. For stern to support
that design. Thirty thank you
less because it's your mother
watching. The but if she has hi
mommy yeah okay thank you all
right thank you very much we
appreciate your input. Thank
you. The next panel- reading
writing counting utilizing
schools to increase
participation of Los Angeles
county office of education- ms
of Jana and brought a. Also a
Los Angeles unified school
district- devore a no Lara read
chief education and litigation
counsel. And then- Long Beach
unified school district Quinn
brown program administration.
In once again I'm still
confident we can all read so if
there's anything you'd want to
supplement we're happy to
receive it so let me begin
with- Los Angeles county of
education Mrs with Jana. I'm
driving. Good afternoon.
Honorable chairs and members of
the committee my name is
Viviane Andrade on the general
counsel for the Los Angeles
county office of education
which is of course the largest
county office in the state I
would like to acknowledge and
thank the governor's office the
Senate and assembly leadership
for making local educational
agency census out reach a
budget priority the trust that
you placed in us and the
investment that you have made
is really critical to a
positive outcome on the census.
After all all of the research
unequivocally shows that
schools and teachers are the
trusted messengers we all come
from cultures where the words
of love my yes throughout or in
my S. throw are held in high
esteem the money that's been
allocated to what now amounts
to nine hundred and sixty three
schools we will be put to great
use by the forty three find it
hard to count school districts.
So I'd like to speak to you
about the efforts we've we have
under way but let me start
first by addressing the
curriculum I it in the census
curriculum census twenty twenty
count me in it's been an in
process over the past several
years the purpose is to educate
students and teachers the
historical importance of the
sexes its function the use of
data the importance of the
complete count. And advocacy
products of projects and I. one
under find out because the
project because I think that's
really really important. Up the.
The our killer was specifically
designed it was created by
teachers it was tested. To
online to California history
social science standards it's
short it's concise it's easily
implemented. And it includes a
taking action type approach to
energize and to equip students
to organize campaigns to also
assist in getting out a
complete count. And examples
include student develop posters
PSAs brochures assemblies
presentations to parents. Add
to their community groups. I
see that those that those
projects are really important
because- what's become really
clear to us. Is that as we
rolled out the census
curriculum we married it with
with legos outreach efforts.
And in the past couple of
months we convened a hundred
sixteen. Our educators in LA
county. Twenty two came from
the out reach funded districts.
And we had some teachers
actually bring students to are
convening. And it was amazing
when you saw the students and
their interest and they're of.
Absolute interest because they
get it and we know that kids. A
large part some of our students
are going to play a very very
important part. In this in the
census in working with their
families because after all when
we look. At the role that
students play historically
sometimes they've been
translators and interpreters
for our community this time out
what's really fascinating is
that those kids are tech savvy
they know how to do it. And as
long as they have access to the
internet and they have access
to the resources they're gonna
lead and help lead their
parents. In making sure that
the census is completed. So I'm
as part of the curriculum that
that we have it's really
focused and we're hoping that
there will be school districts
and some of the schools that
will focus on. Our. Having
students play and continue to
play that that role in part by.
Part by perhaps of sponsoring
online video competitions or
other creative type efforts
aimed at students because we
understand they're the ones
that are going to benefit
ultimately of from the census
outreach so let me talk a
little bit about the outrage
that we have under way on
December third earlier this
month we convened
representatives. From the forty
three school districts
virtually all of them were
present and those that were not
present were present virtually
of we anticipated the
importance of having nonprofit
partners present so some of the
people that came and spoke to
you earlier today we're at our
convening- and it was a
fabulous. A fabulous fabulous
convening all we had nonprofits
such as not Leyva we have non
profits such as- the
advancement project the other
thing we did which was
absolutely critical is that we
used the resources from the
California community foundation
and we provided a
communications type training
for the school districts that
were there. Our thanks to the
of the work of fountain which I
have to tell you was absolutely
fabulous it's online it's a
open sourced and it and it
really allows school districts
do the things that they need to
do which is to have ready
resources in hand ready to ride
because really the I. which
piece of this. Is gonna come
face to face person to person
and allowing teachers and
allowing educators to do that
work in the time to do that
work is really critical and not
have it bad I- doing things
like having to create a
separate documents but to be
able to share all the resources
so that was certainly the work
that we were doing a we're
continuing to do that. We look
forward to- take to continue to
partner with all of the school
district. Thank you ms and
rather. Our next Los Angeles
unified school district
misread. Thank you so much
committee members it's an honor
to be part of this panel. On
behalf of Elian the fight
school district. For LA unified
and many school districts in
the state so much is at stake.
When it comes to serving our
highest needs population. LA
unified is the largest school
district and state as you met
me very well no. And we are
work very well positioned to
reach a wide range of hard to
count populations and
leveraging the services and
resources. Over thirteen
hundred and twenty two schools
and centres. Into activating
them into census- action kiosks
and other- and other.
Activities and targeted areas
were hardest account
communities. The district has
already incorporated a lot of
the information for census and
to our we are one LA unified
campaign- much of our efforts
this year and into next year we
are leveraging the we are one
LA unified campaign and to
making it. We are one LA
unified make LA unified count.
The district has. Over sixty
thousand employees which we
hope we will leverage as our
senses messengers we have
embedded partners not only-
internally with our labor
partners and associations. We
have started engaging with our
labor partner such as you tell
a M. as C. I. you- in
immigration efforts and we will
continue to do so for census
efforts. The district has a lot
of organizations within it and
we will leverage those as well
we have the division of adult
and career education. Which
serves over seventy thousand
students annually in its
programs they have about
eleven- mean adult education
centers in over a hundred for
the satellite locations which
we will use for census action
chaos as well. We have the
beyond the bell program which
provides before and after
school programming they are
currently at the height six
hundred and thirty five school
sites and they have about fifty
four hundred part time team
members who have direct
supports who offer direct
supports daily. To parents and
to students. Since the zero to
five age group is the most
undercounted age group in the
nation LA unified has a unique
opportunity to reach those
parents in our multiple early
education programs. With over
thirteen thousand children
currently enrolled in our
educational center programs we
will leverage our teachers and
our early ad centers in two
senses active- section action
kiosks so while. We also have a
parent community service this
branch which focuses on family
engagement and we have about
five hundred family centers
throughout the school district
which will be used for census
information centers. And lastly
we have our students. And our
students I've used I've heard
they use the word used-
numerous times during this-
committee hearing as
ambassadors and our students
are going to be our greatest
ambassadors I echo what miss
Andrade said. That students are
going to be the conduit to our
families. And to their extended
families and communities so we
plan on engaging our students
and having student led efforts
into the census. I just wanted
to again thank this committee
and also the legislature for
recognizing that schools are
the nucleus of a community and
we are the trusted partners in
the community in an for using
the resources into the schools
thank you very much. Thank you
mystery a Mister brown. Good
afternoon. Excuse me US senator
Umberg- senator pan and
assembly member- Bergman and
other distinguished committee
members- my name is Clinton
brown and I work on other
deputies superintendent's
office and I'm glad to be here
to represent the Long Beach
unified school district.
Efforts to this point and- I
won't reiterate a lot of the
things that I just heard I'll
just talk to you about just
some of the activities that
we've done we are very proud to
be co chairs- with the city of
Long Beach you heard from
Mister Jackson earlier. The
first effort we've we did-
about a month ago is our
superintendent put out a memo
to all of our Long Beach
unified school district
stakeholders- that touches over
two hundred thousand people.
Are just talking about the
senses the importance and- if
we don't count all the people
in our particular city. Then
there will be certain cut so we
were very transparent in the
importance of that. We to a
plan to utilize our family
resource centers to house some
of the- census- chaos is- and
we are targeting those hard to
count communities- in the city
of Long Beach. We serve over
seventy seventy two thousand
students in the district and
over eighty thousand employees
so we feel that we can touch
the entire. Spectrum of the
city of Long Beach. We have
also started through our public
information a department we
started a social media blast-
informing people about the
senses were the kiosks will be
located- also we will have. At
every school site will will we
will have a place for parents
and guardians of community
members to actually come and do
the questionnaires take the
senses we just have a place
where they could get more
information about the senses.
And just have that. As my
colleague said a trusted
partner in this effort. We also
have. We met with us a
representative from the US
census bureau in regards to
the- count me in curriculum so
we have started working with
our district curriculum leaders
to develop additional lesson
plans that we're going to kick
off in the month of January
that will touch all of our
students K. through twelve- in
a social sciences were good
also wrote about an arm in our
math classes. Are science
classes and also our English
classes as well. And let's see
here. Of course we're going to
utilize a some of the
information at our PTA meetings
are paired forums- we touch a
lot of people through head
start we're going to do some
work with. Informing our
parents through our education
celebrations that we have
throughout the district. And
again- we're gonna really
utilize our students because
again they are the. You know
the we feel like they're on
they there at the grassroots
they're going to go home and
talk with their parents and
tell them about the importance
of the senses so we have-
started training all of our
associated student bodies
across the district and having
them work- in our particular
schools and classrooms to also
get the word out to parents.
And we were part of the- legal
senses twenty twenty convening
a last week which I feel was
very powerful and very-
informative and so we were able
to take some of that
information back so we feel
like we're ready to go. And we
have done some great work with
Kevin and Julia Senate off I've
heard his name a couple times
he's he's excellent and- we
look forward to continue with
the work. So that we can. Count
every person in the city of
Long Beach thank you- thank you
Mister brown I'm gonna turn the
gavel over to. My co chair
senator pan for just a few
moments. Well thank you so very
much for your presentations-
chairman Anderson you had a one
lead off first. Yeah I'll be
great- and thank you so much
for all the work that you're
doing in the schools I totally
agree that our students are-
the maybe undervalued- it
resource and trust the
messenger for their families-
and so. And M. day as somebody
else earlier mentioned a
captive audience- at least for
the ones that show up- and so
you know real opportunity to
educate them about the
importance and have them.
Spread that message. I don't
know to if you were here for
the first panel we talked a
little bit about- how were
falling short in terms of our
new were a numerator
recruitment- and hiring and
when. I think it was mis read
was talking about adult ADD-
yeah- that made me realize that
that could be a great-
potential resource for
enumerators- and then so. Would
encourage you to let them know
about the opportunities- I did
confirm with my staff that. You
know enumerators do not have to
be full time- they can working
nights and weekends. So
another. Resource could be-
substitute teachers- and folks
who were just looking to make
you know some some extra money-
because were were falling short
need to get as creative as
possible and in. Reaching our
numerator recruitment. A goal
so thought. Those can be to be
that potential pools of
applicants. Thanks. Okay other
questions no all right of all I
just first of all I just want
to thank you so much for your
work I and- really the role and
I know that senator AHS been
the- big champion in the
capital for- for involving
schools with the census and
make sure that you have the
resources to. Make that happen.
Is the one question I would
have for you. Is that you know.
Night editor for example Long
Beach it's actually that they
could committee's co chaired by
both those mentioned by the LA
you a step the- school district
sorry Isaiah. Long Beach school
district yeah and also the C.
so it's a great example of
collaboration. In terms of- I
he just touch maybe about how
your so you're what you're
teaching the curriculum I know
that's something that you know
we've fashion states of Roth.
Terms how the school district
is interfacing with. Let's say
some of the CBO stuff about
language access and other types
of things so. And it's great
you were trying to come up
people lots of different-
actions right you know the kids
going to come home and tell
them about it right to go see
something out there hopefully
you hear read something about
it. So just in terms of you
know obviously schools as
centers of our communities they
you interface a lot we have
parent teacher organizations
the idea of community
organizations all around the
school. How how's your C. high
school districts- tapping into
serve your networks of
relationships that you have
with- the surrounding
communities around your school.
And then- how that interfaces
with- the sort of the various
committees that- we've- heard
from here today can you just.
Talk about that and how to use
it of course is that and how
the students. Are you work with
that perhaps the plugin
students who might be
interested. The one of the one
of the first things we did when
we did our convening was to
invite the nonprofit partners.
I have to say I think sometimes
it's a real challenge. Of not
because the non profits are not
willing because they're they're
they're ready they're- giving.
Out sometimes it's really the
education. Community that needs
to figure out how how best to
use it they may not have- a YA
and infrastructure that's just
not ready to pull them in. So
that for us I think is one of
the challenges. I and it is a
it is certainly a challenging
one that that we're continuing
to work on. And to and to try
to bring as many partners as we
can add. To the schools. Are so
that they so they can so that
they can link I think we all
recognize the importance. Of
building communities and
needing this in in the way that
we can so that there's no- so
that there's no repetition.
Unnecessary repetition that
we're not inventing reinventing
the wheel every every which way
but- but for us I think that
use. That use a challenge and I
think earlier we heard the Long
Beach forces say the same thing
it's sort of. Trying to figure
out how best to break in and to
and to become partners- so for
so for us we certainly see
that. Their appreciate your
acknowledging also that.
Forming partnerships and three
of the infrastructure is not
something just happens
magically it takes time and
effort and resources it's not
something that you know
oftentimes people talk like me
Bates organizations like- you
do this work can you. You know
jun join our group. And they're
like okay my calendars full of
like I gotta get this group and
I gotta do my real work right
on the edge even get paid for
baby I get paid for sometimes
not. So appreciate recognizing
that. We are actually very
fortunate at LA unified school
district to have very engaging
robust partnerships with a lot
of our community based
organizations. It really began-
couple years ago when we formed
our we are one LA unified
campaign standing with
immigrant families. And through
that campaign we have-
interface would many immigrant-
organizations chair lack of
this and- and- the California
community foundation has been a
great supporter of our we are
one LA unified campaign. So it
feels like as we enter into our
census work and we're
transitioning into their are we
are one make LA unified. Count
campaign it seems almost like a
seamless transition we are
engaging with most of the same
organizations. In our senses-
much of our partners who were
from the previous panels we've
had meanings and part of that
as long. As well as our
partnership with late goal- and
L. unified we are- as part of
the legal office looking into
M. O. use would CBO's. And
having them assist in our
senses outreach efforts as
well. And that is one of one of
the points that we will be. Of
leveraging continue to leverage.
And I want to echo that as
well- when I first attended the
meeting several months ago and
saw the partners that were in
there from the CBO's. Those
particular organizations are
already in our school system so
we are. Already in alignment
with him and- issues again it's
seamless so we are on board
and- they attend some of our
events and vice versa so we're
working collaboratively with
an- intestine. Okay well I
think the question no. Once
that so all right well thank
you so very much for your
presentations and you're very
important work on census thank
you. And thank you pass a back
to some Robert. All right next
panel. State and federal
updates bowstring local efforts
in meeting requirement excuse
me recruitment needs-
mysterious Carnegie and Yolanda.
Of those Connell
. So miss
Carnegie. Okay so my
performance measure for this
whole exercise is getting
pronunciations correct so right
right right. But we- are what
we go ahead and if- if misa as
Connell is here's miss look the
Scott here. She is here okay
all right. Anthony great we'll
get afternoon honorable chairs
and members thank you for the
invitation to speak today my
name is D. this Kentucky and
I'm the director of the
California complete count since
twenty twenty office we
appreciate the ongoing
collaboration and support of
the legislature to ensure that
California is ready to achieve
our fair share of resources and
representation. In the
decennial census first of all I
wanted to say how proud and
amazed at the work of our
partners- that you've just all
heard about- the integration of
counties and cities sectors
schools community foundations
of that or weaving together. To
create this outrage coverage is
what we need I came back in
twenty seventeen hoping that we
can harness the energy
creativity and commitment of
these partners across sectors
and I'm so relieved that these
committed partners have come
together to get it done. I do
want to give a little shout out
for some early thought leaders
Dorothea park retired from LA
county and doctor John the bard
of the California dancer
project you guys have seen in
the past- presentations talking
about this LA regional table
you know he and I started
conversations back in twenty
seventeen of January when like
nobody was even talking about
census and so he's kind of one
of those quiet leaders that
really kind of thought about
how does this all work how do
we make. The sort of complex
thing going on he also have
leadership within C. pan the
census policy advocacy network
who was instrumental in working
with all of you on our funding.
So I just want to see that
these early folks planted seeds
that have grown into a
tremendous powerful movement so
whether you started working on
census in twenty seventeen or
if you're just coming to the
table today by watching or
participating in this hearing.
Please know that it it won't
just take one village it's
going to take all the ledges to
get this done and again all
efforts are welcome and all
efforts are needed. The
partner's we've heard from
today demonstrate why we're
investing so heavily in our
local ground game. Because they
know. Exactly where to invest
and or in order to educate and
motivate the hardest to count
Californians. As twenty
nineteen comes to end. Or as we
start our fourth quarter full
court full court press. We're
hearing up for January twenty
twenty our office and are
contracted partners are getting
ready to make a shift of our
outreach focus. From the
motivate pays to the activities
and we're gonna strategically
move target audience toward the
action of actually completing.
The questionnaire. However as I
look at the weeks to come and
comparator efforts in two
thousand and two thousand ten.
It is clear that we're facing
barriers on two fronts and
that's how I classify them. The
berries are motivational. And
their structural. When we
overcome the motivational
barriers it means that people
will want to fill out the
questionnaire to help their
families their neighbors their
community. The little trust
that their information is
confidential. And the state's
invested millions in overcoming
these motivational bears. The
structural barriers however.
Are obstacles for how a person
can participate in the sense
that some summer panels touched
on a little bit about that.
These are operations and
processes that are embedded in
the federal government's
administration of the census.
The structural barriers Lee
solely in the hands of the US
census bureau. However
California is a state as
legislators as policy as
partners. We need to be
innovative and help mitigate
the impact of the structural
barriers. As the census our
office role is to provide a
bridge between the census
bureau and our local partners
on the ground. To facilitate
communication information
sharing and provide support and
advocate for solutions that are
innovative and meet the needs
of our local jurisdictions.
There are a number of
structural barriers that our
local partners have been
identifying a bring forth to
the state and asking for
assistance. But I'm just going
to touch on one we touch on
others later in the queue in a-
a structure where that if we
don't help mitigate we put our
count at risk. And that you
guys have started talk about.
The most immediate is
recruitment of enumerators
Harding university is and your
laudable speak about those very
real numbers that each and
every. One of our jurisdictions
needs with our unemployment
rate being so low. The federal
hiring process being so slow.
And the lack of flexibility.
And creativity about how we
meet those hiring goals we are
at a critical crossroads. Again
we want to motivate those to be
counted but if they're not a
Newman- enough Newman is to
knock on doors people don't
self respond. After made may
first hits then we risk all of
those being missed. We are
committed at the state- to
partner with the census bureau
a couple things that we've been
doing to help drive recruitment
we're doing job related posts
on our social media- tool kits.
Our high letting them in our
partner newsletters our senses
dot CA dot gov website includes
information under new jobs
resources all our social media
channels are are pushing out
the message we're finding ways
to integrate with other out
reach works for key audiences
to seniors were doing work with
seniors. College students were
working with all our higher ed
folks and other groups are well
positioned for census bureau
employment positions. This also
includes employed messaging
with labor agency employment
development department and
other labor focus stages
agencies and departments. For
those reaching a possible play
polite cal vet and apartments
retirees and other adults. Also
regardless if our partners are
getting funding. To help with
recruitment I am hopeful that
they'll realize the urgent need
to help. With this recruitment
regardless of their getting
funding. In closing whether the
structural barrier. Or
motivational barrier no one
single group or organization
can achieve a complete count on
their own. Coordinated
collaborative efforts will be
critical to success. And we
look forward to continuing down
this path into our fourth
quarter. To mix metaphors taken
across the goal line. That with
our partners philanthropy
legislature the census bureau
and our other stakeholders to
find solutions. Thank you for
this time in I'm a bill to the
to answer additional cost.
Thank you miss Carnegie our
next miss those Connell. Thank
you for the opportunity I
wanted to thank everyone I'm
sitting here today I just saw
all of the efforts that are
made for the recruitment again
from the state level from the
county level from this city
level and all the committee
based organizations we really
cannot do this without you- as
D. does said- we do need it
does take everyone to get a
complete count so. I did kind
of have a power point just
candidates speak on a little
bit of progress of the census
bureau what we're doing.
Richard all. Okay. So. Okay I.
if they don't break there will
okay so it's just an update- as
far as recruiting update
offered today. I just wanted to
start off with California. So
the California numbers if you
can see from the slide. We have
over. Leave it's. All recording
goal for the state of
California offer California
we're at forty two days this
was the number as- Monday but
as of today were at forty four
point 5% of our recruiting
goal. Are the goal for. Our
California offices on the next
slide always show you just what
we're doing we do have thirty
offices that are located
strategically in California and
that's to support all of our
numerators all of our field
work. Again we have three
offices in central California.
We got ten in northern
California and we have about
seventeen offices offices
specifically in the southern
California area. Because this
meeting focused on Los Angeles
county and Orange County just
wanted to bring up some of the
numbers for Los Angeles county
about a- but more over a week
ago we were at 38% so as of
today and this is the updated
number for today's forty one
percent. This we put it
together yesterday so as you
can see. It is slowly moving
upward where we need to be- the
other things for Orange County
it's over seventeen thousand a
new. Recruits for that area
right forty six point eight
percent. So we're slowly moving
up and again this flight was as
yesterday at the numbers that I
just spoke right now our what
we're doing actually today. So
we did look those up on. Where
are progresses and we're
removing. On the other. Slide
that we're talking about is
most people that's what's our
language goal. And if using
some of the committee based
organizations a lot of them on
the census bureau website. They
use the- planning database. So
again with the geography as we
spoke about- each track with at
least 5% of the population
primaries begin on English
language. And again that's
according to the planning
database they created a
language recruiting goal for-
the census bureau's non
response follow up operation.
So the language recruiting on
these tracks is equal to the
percentage of population
speaking that language it
multiplied by the non response
follow up recruiting goal or
one or whichever is greater.
And overall we have goals for
thirty eight different
languages and we have over a
hundred and ten thousand nine
hundred thirty. Total
applicants with a language
skill. Next labor gonna talk
about is our recruiting
strategies and again. You are
part of Dodd integral-
recruiting strategy and that's-
reaching out to again. As
everybody mentions is a higher
education- we've targeted.
Private companies companies we
use worn less when companies
are going out to offer census
bureau jobs- we work with a lot
of job local job centers with
good will we are coordinating
with companies and others to
hire holiday season workers. So
just as their jobs and then our
jobs will begin- were engaged
again partners- to assist with
the recorded message and you
are our partners and we are
counting on you to get the word
out about census jobs. We
didn't put on your social
media- but we need those
trusted voices so that people
could resonate with them
respond are the other thing we
wanted to talk about additional
strategies is we do have
recruiting assistance those are
boots on the ground. All all
most of our recruiting
assistance begin other language
our partnership team our
partnership team is really an
integral part in recruiting as
well we work hand in hand that
reach out to the- to our all of
the community based
organizations in the complete
count committees and they're
very well versed in. Just
languages as well we've got
we've increased and exhilarated
our paid advertisement and
nationally they're going M.
started recruiting complex
number six million dollars to
get the word out about census
jobs and distances were met.
Where is very and a postcard
Ben are directly to each
household in some counties that
we were under the goal than
them each in the household.
Again this is kind of a
California map on where our app.
Did you Ben. The light color is
three yeah which is the lowest
count running in a county and
the dark. His color is about
ten plus ads running in one
place and again does include
radio social media. Digital
newspaper ads mall billboards
in movie theaters. And we want
to encourage everyone to apply
we can do a lot of work duties
advertisement but if there's
not a voice with that- trusted
person. Can encourage people to
apply for the census jobs. We
need to kind of get that
message across our hiring
timeline. This information is
available on our website they
did a very good job on putting
all of the information on art
twenty twenty census jobs
website. As far as hiring.
Timelines and again. Last but
not least how you can help.
Again we're encouraging you to
get the word out- right now
it's not it's at the back
burner of everyone's mind we
have thirteen recruiting weeks
left after this week so right
now it's- we have to instill a
sense of urgency this is coming
and this is coming very quickly
and it's great that we have all
in tears but we also want those
volunteers at the numerators
anyone that has a full time job
can do this part time. It's a
new census this time around
going to have an iPhone because
they can do the work it's a lot
easier and again I will have my
business card we have some
handouts- we got some
information everything is
digital a lot of partner
researches on our website-
anything you can do to get the
word out I am available for
questions. Again my name's
along blizzcon I put the
contact information should you
have any questions and again
thank you for the opportunity.
So thank you very much our
senator Russell. Yes. Thank you
both very very much. Since you
are provided miss less Connell-
the percentage of or the total
goal for a numerous that you
want a higher per per county.
It seems and maybe you can go
back to where we're at
currently. It seems were really.
This is really at a time period
that's very tight soul. What
are your thoughts about how to.
Increase the number in such a
short time period is- if you
could go back to that- that's
one question and then for both
of you is. How would you gauge.
A more successful campaign to
do the census all we know were
hard to count and in our part
of in California overall but
especially in this area- how
would you gauge that we did
better we did where we should I
know were. You know looking for
a 100% but- how would you how
would you gauge it is they're-
taking twenty ten and adding a
certain percentage or- what we
shooting for here. So as far as
numbers- again they take in
consideration of the workload
to the goals are established
are based on the work load
based on if the county has the
area census office located or
not- and also offer refusal
rates that we've experienced
and does offer refusal rates
are very between counties in
offices and that's kind of one
of our- biggest challenges
right now because of the
unemployment rate. And then
also kind of. It's a different.
Different environments some
some of the other people are
not interested in- at that
point that's where we need a
selling point it's going to
work a lot better one on one
speaking to people or having
the trusted voices. Share those
messages because if not the
kind of just gonna scroll to
the job. And looked as
interested but yes those goals
are met are based on- again
the- some are not implement
rates were there the county
contains- officer not office.
Refusal rate also that we've
experienced in the hiring
process. Alright some gonna
nerd out on you and you can
just stop me on that so. I mean
there are many ways we're doing
a lot of valuation because I
know centers can ask about that
we're looking at a valuation
for- at the macro level of how
we're moving. You know
attitudes but really the stuff
that you're all going to look
at is response rates. So if you
really look at self response
rates verses when they do nor
for the knocking on doors were
they get the hundred percent.
Looking at how the US census
bureau nationally says they're
gonna target sixty point five.
Like they're expecting sixty
point five. Percent of
households to self respond
meeting they do it online they
do on the phone what have you
that. Before Mar- may first
rate. So for me I don't know
how far that is because we are
facing a lot of unprecedented.
Issues so what I would look at
is I break it down into time
periods because we're we're
doing such data intensive work
with our partners. And I would
look at you obviously have to
look at census tracts geography
geographically that tower
tracking it. We're looking at
twenty ten census. Tract rates
for those dates so let's just
take- a the census tract or
here in Long Beach this call it
zero zero dash one. We're gonna
look at on April first just
take a date where were they in
twenty ten. In terms of their
response rate. And where they
now in twenty twenty and we're
doing that across the state
looking at comparing those so
we can get sort of a semi real
time look at dashboard wise.
And how we're doing. So that's
just one Mike when you're
talking about response rates
now in terms of metrics. I mean
how many questions assistance
centers DB establish. How many
of. How much usage to begin how
may touches that we get there
because with questioner since
centers we're hoping that you
know there are a 100% in terms
of completion verses like
somebody just. Taking something
Allen vent. We can look at.
Schools using creek. For having
it's so important and school
takes a long time to get that
moving and to change the
curriculum and for the first
time we have curriculum that's
actually made by teachers and
accepted for the California
standards also looking at
social media I mean that's the
easiest hits where would how
many people are engaging how
many people are commenting. So
those are just some of the
things M. you can get down to
the census track to see if were
the centrist tractors are point
one is at 11% percent response
rate on April first and they
were at you know 28% last time
around we can track it for
maybe a couple days to see if
because of online and then how
to read read to see how to
redeploy a Long Beach forward
to say Hey look at the census
tracks. Go do an event set up a
table you know go to whatever
you that the minister that's
there have them deploy
immediately and then see if
that's going to change it so
that was different about this
time our hours are getting real
to if you thank- but at the end
of you know fifteenth we'll get
a snapshot look at where
response rates are and then the
this group has to make up. And
to all those you know only get
50% they could not on fifth.
Sent more possible to get that
people can. In center pan.
Thank you M. that I appreciate
the challenges of especially in
a good economy which we do
like- and I would point out
that actually he. That de
should California economy I.
she's been consistently growing
faster than the rest of the
country for many years- and so
I think it's testament to
California policies and
economic growth but that's
mental side comment. So the
question now I want to cut back
the nation right. Well it's
also fairly directly straits
right okay I'm not going there-
the so the question I have to
ask for you though is that so
I've now I know you're in
southern California I'm up in
Sacramento and I've been trying
to get people to talk about-
working for the census to do
numeration and I appreciate-
the- discussion about. That's a
structural issues will have
enough enumerators were not
going to be able to get to as
many people- the thing is some
the feedback I get is well
earlier on was is that it took
a long time for them to even
hear D. will hear anything.
Right so the plan application
they just don't hear anything
and- then there are you know
they start losing interest in
of course looking for other
jobs and so forth so. Hopefully
as we're getting closer to
crunch time that gap in time
between city an application and
hearing something is closed and
isn't as more instantaneous-
the other thing though I also
here's because we want we have
a diverse state and we want a
diverse set of enumerators- for
example in forty communities of
color. We have higher
percentages of people who've
had a history of conservation
no are the record. And to what
degree that a barrier to them
working for the census right
they they want they're looking
for work they want to do
something. Maybe can speak to
that- my guess is that you
probably not carried with those
of documentation. From me but
that's another but the two
wives were taking out big
chunks large chunks of people
out of the pool. So I guess one
of the things that went that
maybe clarity is that so- how
who can apply you know who who
who who can be employed by the
census to do this work I mean-
it's sometimes not clear and I
think there's a lot of stuff
going around the community
about that- and so people.
Don't even wanna try is there
for you know they think they
won't Shotton. They're not so.
I think that. You can clarify a
not next to sheeting detail
given factor hearing comprise
more writing but perhaps a
broad stroke as to. Who really
realistically has a decent
chance of getting a job with
the senses of the take the time
and effort of actually
submitting an application.
Great so the first thing is who
can apply everyone can apply it
but yes there are some factors
that may be. Made not make us
your filter down to a
successful employee what does
that look like when you apply
online we don't have background
questions an initial
application. So those. Issues
are handled on a case by case
basis so say somebody has
something other can become a
criminal background we can't
say this offense or this
doesn't they take a lot of
factors into consideration.
Which is to be the time period
of what should happen to the
extent of whatever the- you
know what the issue was. So
those are handled by a case by
case basis so again everyone
can apply when they're hired.
The national form that'll
probably bring is the
declaration for federal
employment and so the
employment is they do have to
disclose. That information and
if there's something that
warrants additional information
this time around they are given
up about sixty days to respond
to that okay let me let me push
back a little bit on this I
appreciate you saying well
everybody can fly by the way.
That could undocumented people
it includes and I'm well. I'm
just. Hello right yeah they can
apply but they may not be
eligible now they- know about a
meter I mean the things he is
able to be applied but for
example they don't
realistically have a chance of.
Getting in like they can
provide a social security
number and really the answer is
no they shouldn't. Right so I'd
so I guess and then I get the
idea that. Case by case. Basis
but the problem is. The
feedback I'm getting is that.
They realize there isn't like
maybe sharp lines. Problem
probably the Thursday. The
thirtieth but some guidance is
helpful because I think there
are people who are said well I
don't want to. Bother doing
this because I don't think I
have much of a chance and I can
go and tell them well
everybody's your of life but-
you know people talk to each
other and community right I'm
trying to be a truck. If I'm
going to trust the messenger I
got to be communicate to people
about realistically. You know
if you got these offenses you
should definitely so go because
there's a good chance they'll
still hire you if. You're kind
of got involved in something
let's say you're his Vidak you
know you got felony probably
not. You know because people
don't want you knocking on the
door so I mean I think. Some
clear guidance. May actually
help to try to communicate this
is back to trusted messenger
issues right. Questions can I
be a trusted messenger I just
go and say everybody can apply
I'm- I think my trusted part
starts going down because I'm
not being. Realistic and direct
with them. And that's what I
kind of. They realize that in
Pratt C. official had you can't
get but I mean some. That's
going to be important to be
able to communicate to people
M. vertically communities in
three communities wanna get
numerators from because they'll
be best at regionals
communities what kind of
direction we can give them so
is there getting the word out
that they can give people. The
straight answer so that they
can still remain trusted. Right
and does it our eligibility
questions that they're not
getting any finite answers for
it because again those are all
reviewed on a case by case
basis because there's so many
factors to those. But yes
normally I would use a
declaration for federal
employment as a guide I anyone
can Google that and it'll ask
background questions. As far
as- if you're you're on
probation they go back- five
years- there's one question go
seven years so that's the base
line that the federal
government uses. For jobs so if
you're giving that information
I would direct them to the
declaration for federal
employment- that's available
online that's an office of
personnel management form that
this in in this is that also
available I mean is the you
put. That aside from having to
only go find- M. B. is that
something that's on this it's
on the census bureau of
personal website which is since
the start garbage hiring
documents. So it's part a
hiring document yes for the
hiring document because yes
does questions in those things
will come into play at the
point of hiring when you first
apply those questions are not.
On the initial application so
it does happen at the point of
higher now there's some people
that you may talk to maybe they
had something that happened
long time ago or were in when
they were younger. And again.
Our message should be in the
community based organizations
to help them complete that
information so if there's
feedback that's required maybe
those coming based
organizations can. Help them
complete the letter help them
clear up anything there's a lot
of issues sometimes it's around
this information want to clear
that up as well. So I think the
follow up and again the great
job that the committee based
organizations are doing it will
help people but yes. The normal
guide that most federal
agencies use is that
declaration for federal
employment it's on the census
dot gov website under hiring
documents. And I'm anyone can
look Google the declaration for
federal employment that a lot
these give you the background
questions that you're subject.
To so that you can be prepared
for them. Okay thank you. The
seven member Berman. Thank you
very much to. Hopefully quick
questions the first is. So we-
had kind of macro level. Data
on- the percent of applicants
that we have so far and what
the goals are. Is there any
kind of more micro level data
in terms of in trying to. Find
bilingual speakers in certain
languages and whether or not
we're falling short- in certain
communities on. On some of the
more specific skill sets that
were trying to. You know get
with with folks that are
applying to be enumerators.
That's the first question
second questions unrelated toss
up there for now. So the
language gold we do have our
language gold sad to- for the
most part we've been meeting
those and I can go back to see
if we can share those at least
most of the language goals were
we've said we're at a hundred
percent. Okay are meeting our
language goals Scott good to
know- in the same question as
it was kind of misinformation
and disinformation which has
been a huge concern of mine- on
the on the election front but
also obviously that applies to
the census friends under pan
and I doctor Ben and I we-
participated in the meeting.
Like a year and a half ago now-
we're we kind of you had. We
were scared straight about that
what could happen- as we get up
to census day- where is there a
process where people can go if
they see things out in the
community or on social media.
That they think are inaccurate-
in regards to the census where
that- the where they can report
something and that information
will get filtered up and then
maybe it is our plan to
communicate with different
social media platforms. To make
sure that they're pulling
things down as quickly as
possible if there's
misinformation being sprayed on
the platforms. Certainly the
census bureau headquarters they
do have a team that's looking
at that looking at social media
so any of the negative they
pretty much. Are are on it to
get those- taken care of- but
the phone numbers are listed
there and yes- that's the hard
part in it applies to jobs as
well because everyone that's-
Google in at- again if you have
a like an eighteen. At the
Google everything Sir according
to my son I don't work for the
census bureau because he Google
button he called the wrong
office and I don't work there.
Right you have to be careful I
would say just send everyone to
the official website. Twenty
twenty census dot gov for
information. There's numbers
there we have the toll free job
find that's on all of the
information that they can be
transferred to. A we have to be
careful with mirror sites- and
they've applied ended up
applied to the census jobs. My
son accidentally. On apply to
job had. Questions that we
didn't have it has the census
bureau logo. Login as much as
possible direct them to the
official site make sure it has
Dodd god at the end. I don't
trust anything that says dot
com. But yes since you're does
have some- things in place in
regards to on things it'll come
up on social media that they
can- attacked directing removed
if it's- yeah. Even beyond the
whole jobs so I worked as a
video online that do you know
is a testimonial somebody
saying I opened the door to a
census taker and- and ice was
with them. Right yeah II is
there something you know it it
will there be. A different go
to the senses website will
there be a link or a job down
or anything that says like. You
know if you reporter
misinformation that you saw-
please is a rumors at census
Dodd goes the exam. That they
can report it to okay- and then
I know at national headquarters
working with Dan avoid it like
they're actually coming up with
the process nationally. Yeah to
try Jeff and we're walking at
this. Work with it because
things that star in New
Hampshire. May seem innocuous
but- and epidemiology he will
want to watch to see. How it
spread Richard can see this. So
we can inoculate in California
yeah against those messages
service. Yeah it's the same
thing I you know that we saw
meddling in elections in like
small random south. American
countries. Before they metal
Marlys. As in twenty sixteen
and we can anticipate that
they're gonna test things out
in other communities- before
they- in March you. Will be
able to see. What they're doing
with our primary as well
exactly. Great but we can find
out exactly and provide that
information to see if it's
going to be on their website or
if there's gonna be a specific
number for this. Person center
pan. Asian just follow up. And
yet appreciate all the work the
census bureau's doing. I'm
actually concerned when you
said there are mere sites to
the census okay. Yeah it's very
easy to go. Dot com verses dot
gov so that's a really simple
straightforward thing to do.
And if you can get and I
realized- limits to what the
federal government can do it
since broken do but if you
can't solve that problem of
like taking down or getting
people to pull down your sites
are buying up the domain names
for those. That's a really
straightforward thing to do.
And if you can't handle that I
am very worried about what
happens on the something a lot
more sophisticated than that.
Okay if you're Denver so short
on jobs and- yet we can't keep
people from landing on the mere
sight. Because they type dot
converse dot gov. I mean let's
let's hueso selected officials
we have to deal with campaigns
we have we know you by every
dummy site if you can if you
have the resources that gets
around because you just don't
want people. Basically tricking
people into going somewhere
else and putting out
misinformation about you. So I
would C. say that if that's
really going on and then that's
your first test of what you can
try to do with this information
if you can't get the- the- I.
T. community and all the other
folks that help you and say
look you know what this is
misinformation and- people who
are applying for the census
were desperate trying to get.
Are getting diverted and
getting their- who knows
they're doing it because
they're stealing personal ID
information whatever reason
they're doing it. We can't shut
those people down- then we have
a big problem because- we don't
have a- in and you should be
all shut down tomorrow because
that's about how fast you go to
work when people first hits
right if you can't if you takes
you couple weeks to shut up and
down like that. It's over the
game's over it the words
already out you know it's only
takes a few days for something
go viral. And so- I hope that
we should be Dodd that. The
people who are working on this
stuff they should use as
perhaps as a test. Case of what
they can try to do to mobilize
the community the stop
misinformation. Yeah and they
understand that- the ones for
jobs it's job boards like job
hats those are the ones that
are are kind of a top because
they say we have census jobs.
And they've got their
disclaimers on that but I'm
Richard the census bureau is
working out to make sure that
it's safe and secure. So this
is a follow so what's the plan
to get rid of those sites. Read
them the ones that we had. This
would they were like job had to
we had for. The G. twenty
twenty jobs most people for
example the by the key words
like job had indeed .com
because we do post on them for
jobs. But sometimes those. Job
boards also. Kind of gather the
information on that on some of
the applicants. So we- they've
got a big campaign in place we
bought. Was been a lot of money
on key words to make sure that
the census bureau was right on
top as far as- census jobs. So
that kind of happened early on
but again. I'm talking about
job hot. Indeed dot com will
ultimately they do take you to
the census bureau website but
they're pretty much. Job boards
okay so there's no more mirror
sites is that right now there's
no more mers all right. Then
answers the question- a couple
things first of all- thank you
both for being here you both
have. Significant challenges in
different ways. Of his Carnegie
thank you for your
responsiveness we've asked many
questions of the course last
year and you've been very
responsive thank you very much
for that- the- where where are
we in terms of metrics in terms
of enumerators in California.
We what. Where are we. So for
killing I think I gave the
California number open in terms
of where you expect to be where
are we are at. For California
we are at forty four and a half
percent what what's reform its
metric for this time of year.
We expect to be pretty close
250% so we're getting there and
again this number changes every
single day right. So we're
below where we expect to be
right. So what's the plan in
February to accelerate that
process we started accelerating
our process now again the
census bureau put a just now
finding and for paid
advertisement- increase a goal
they've increased our staffing
so we have additional recording
assistance additional boots on
the ground what. How much have
we increased our staffing here
in California to meet our goal
the last California can got
back to the actual number but
nation I mean for our whole
region- we've increased it. By
two to three hundred recording
assistance I see a six point
five million nationwide is so
small that it's infinitesimal-
and I realize that you're not.
Here because you're running the
senses for the country but six
point five million nationwide
is. Is a pebble in the great
lake. So is there a plan and if
there's not a plan will there
be a plan and will you let us
know what that plan is because
if we're if we're behind by say
8% now. M. we turns out in
February were still behind.
There in there's no work plan
to accelerate recruitment. What
what what happens. We've
started now again the national
campaign is kicking into a D.
distilling to our regional
efforts we've got the National
Kevin going they just started
at this week so we've increased
all of our recruiting efforts
all of our media. Can you let
us know when a month where we
if not you may be miss Carnegie
can let us know where you are
in a month and have you reached
out to legislative offices I C.
reset aggression offices you
reset the legislative offices
our partnership to. The group
that reaches out to legislative
office to- engage their support
site but yeah we're reaching
out and every level of that we
can and again there's national
partnerships that are taking
place as well I don't want to
be sarcastic here but I'm-
pretty sure no one's reached
out to our office I don't know
about other members it. Is
anybody reach out to your
offices from the national. The
federal government. Jim. Right
what will we'll find out but-
just drawing from I'll take
that information back thing
right right so far as I know-
then lastly missed Mr Escovedo
testified a little earlier
about certain challenges I
asked him what his number one
challenge was in his number one
challenges- I can't remember
exactly what he said but
something about- the changing
rigorous flexibility whatever
it may be requirements in if
each of you could respond to
his comment in and- you know.
What to do about it so let me
start with miss- Kentucky thank
you so- yes FAA Jean was
talking about there is a four
page guidance that came out
about how can committee great
bit based groups help on the
ground- any in that particular
document there were two
references to it's against
federal law to do phone you
know to do phone banking or to
call folks robo calls and it's
against the law- I think it was
to- to give a tablet at the
door and so our lawyers owns
long as as well as some other.
Advocates lawyers have been
looking at that and they cannot
find the federal we've asked
for the federal law that it's
against- and so that's where I
think there's some angst at
least from our office as well
as a lot of our partners like a
train because you're giving it
this guidance but it's not
state in any law at if you know
it so that's part of it is how
do we interpret that- and so
we're in the process of trying
to Askar lorries how do we
interpret it if it's there's
nothing enter Brett. I think
that's where the AG's office
been formed- I'm not sure I'll
have to probably should now all
of this is last call for drinks
or whether we're being kicked.
Out but the it's are going off
on so let me let me just. I
don't want to stop your
response yeah if you're
finished them M. turned ms
Connell. What what are your
thoughts on Mr excavators
testimony. I don't know if I
got it's disappointing because
I did a step back but can you
just kind of give me what he
said was is I. S. was biggest
challenge and what he said was
biggest challenges that. And
I'm paraphrasing now is that
the requirements of the federal
government one seem to be
inconsistent with- what they
understand is standard practice
so for example making phone
calls. In that they keep
changing so I. Is that does
that do any visibility on that.
Does that relate to our
employees working with the
census can you that that
relates to so for example if
I'm running community based
organization I want to make
phone calls to people to
community. After you know April
ten I see that a certain
precinct is not being
responsive. So if I wanna make
phone calls to individuals in
that precinct. According to- I
guess the latest guidance
that's a violation of federal
law. However that doesn't seem
to be. The that there's at
least ambiguity there so. Do
you have any comment on that. I
don't have any comment on that
I have to check I think what we
need to do is get that resolved
and maybe maybe the AG's office
can help us get that results
so. Okay thank you very much- I
I. most grateful let me thank
the Senate assembly staff that
are here. I know it is a-
challenge to have hearings
outside the state capitol in a
most grateful for your support.
And also most grateful for the
support of the city of Long
Beach and providing- buses
facility in hosting. And I
think with that we will be
adjourned for. Time being. I'm
sorry I'm sorry yes you're
right you're absolutely right
yes. Let me let me you're right
so let me let me take public
comment here. Right so if you
come up. And you'd identify if
we could actually as people
line up so I could just have
some sort of visuals to those
who wish to testify. And then-
if you could identify yourself
if you're with an organization-
and where you live that would
be most useful- and I'm gonna
ask that we limit ourselves to
two minutes each. Thanks very
much can you hear me yes we
checked as I mazing this I'm
I'm syllabus got on the
director of community relations
for Santa Ana unified school
district I'm also a resident of
Santana. I like to thank you
for the opportunity to speak
today- I'd like to state that
Santa Ana unified has been
engaged in the census is twenty
seventeen with Natalie- and
Moorlach and it is Ben. A part
of our focus for the last year
to ensure that we are
supporting our community and
ensuring that we're all
counted. This year we have
committed my staff- over forty
staff members to be supporting
the practice of family and
community engagement through
that. The active engagement
with our families to make them
aware of what the census is and
how to support him today as a
matter of fact I had over forty
of them we C. professional
development with the Orange
County department of education.
And we've committed to ensuring
that fifty seven of our
wellness centers one at each
one of our schools is going to
be supporting. Not only
information and professional
development for staff but
information for the community
we are open to everyone a
community one of the things
that I wanted to state as that
in September. The district. In
collaboration with them many of
the complete count committees
that we engage in- we start
proclamation the census and all
the parts that were in de
committing to it. And I wanted
to see one thing that is really
concerned as the past couple of
weeks. In November we- what
bands. The P. for the county at.
Orange however not a week ago
we were sadly M. informed that
along with the city of Santana.
Our award letter had been
rescinded so I'm gonna ask for
your support in that. Because
we're still committed and one
of the reasons that is the
district we're asking for this
is to ensure that. All fifty
seven centers are open after
hours so that. Access to them
to all those other families who
are probably working multiple
jobs have access to that. Thank
you so much. Thank you. Thank
you good afternoon my name is
doctor my phone when I am here
representing multiple
organization an intersection
Allen D. it's who I am I'm an
ambassador in that I am
trilingual in the enemy Spanish
and English doctor pan knows me
very well because I've served
on the CMA for the ethnic
medical organization section as
the vice chair. I wanted to
speak to your multiple
wonderful testimonial givers-
there are three populations
that I didn't hear as trusted
messengers positions- currently
I am a house call physicians to
our elderly who do not speak
English mainly Latino and
Vietnamese it's a perfect
opportunity we need to outreach
to our physician members Dr pan
through the lack Monning LA
county medical association-
CME- you need to put us to work
Dr- lastly it's huge about
ethnic media I did not hear-
proper. Appreciation of the
power of ethnic media in little
Saigon where I live in fountain
valley center on both your
district- we have over twelve
of. Legacy newspapers multiple-
radio and television and not
enough has been done there I
reached out here to Nicole I'm
sorry Molly Nichols and the
other folks. The other big
issue is- public charge I come
from an ethnic refugee migrant
org- community there's great
distress and beer that has
been- propagated by this number
forty five administration
unless we acknowledge that-
lastly I'm here as a member of
an incredible CVO. Complete
count it's called- C. senses
Vietnamese we have Latino and
Vietnamese stakeholders and we
have been meeting for three
months and I only heard about
this meeting last night at
midnight on social media so my
plea to you is we are here
geared up- incredibly skillful
and incredibly inter connected.
Please give us adequate lead
time and we are here to partner
with you thank you so much.
Thank you doctor. A good
afternoon my name is Joseph
vigil of I'm the director of
policy and advocacy which
should let the coalition for
humane immigrant rights to
listen to this offers let me
start by thanking you for doing
for you I'm going efforts to
make sure that we reach the
heart to count communities but
also to your staff and they
governor staff that have had
several conversations with us
as relates to what some of the
best practices. For several
years will be working and
getting ready- ourselves but
then also to advocate for
resource as but that's not also
increase partnership with- with
spices with goals by sponsoring
a B. six except without
assemblywoman. Radius that
ensure that schools are part of
the effort. Care less six to
leverage the leverage I'm
sorry. Its presence in the
Inland Empire Orange County. LA
county and to Lara Connie to
implement the census and want
to partner to with many.
Organizations as well but one
of the things that we're
noticing at one of the
challenges the is that. This
bill resource game two to
CBO's. As we hear of they feel
they feel employment they
should we want to make sure
that. Ted the latest by J. de
twenty seven be about million
dollars. Allocated for CBS
actually get to the communities
before I. At January January
first is that we that the plans
are fully implemented. But the
second thing that I also wanna-
highlight ease the- the ongoing
effort by the trump
administration to actually
suppress. The participation of
the census of one of the key
aspect is thick islands. That
were mentioned by Mister
Frankel those are something
that we're trying to really
figure out in Washington DC
what's the purpose of it. Given
the fact that actually tried
the X. and the thing died in
the US census really early on.
And so we're really trying to
figure out and the fact that
when we trying to analyze with
the statue the federal statute
does not make any sense. As it
relates that's waiting one is
up to your office the
governor's office but knows
that the AG's office to really
push for clarification. As it
relates to that. Lastly as as
as as we move forward on the-
there's one eight things that
usually stick to do is to.
Decide. I reject in a in a and
coach. Says anyway and so by
using holidays and that's
something that we will reach
out to. Your offices to trying
to get the help and with that
we appreciate all the work.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
Good afternoon Cheryl Burke
chair of pan and Janet chair.
Berman and Senate a Gonzalez my
name is Natalie dnia I am with
southern California Edison-
here to report that's as C. has
convene internal meetings about
the census starting in
September and created a formal
complete count committee in
November twenty nineteen. In
close collaboration with the
secretary of state and the US
census bureau offices
internally we plan to reach out
to our twelve thousand five
hundred plus employees- by
including census messaging in
our various internal
newsletters digital screens
internal portal website and
department wide meetings.
Externally we plan to reach a
fifteen million. US residents
by including census messaging
in bill inserts bill answered
external newsletters
interactive voice response
system low income and energy
program communications social
media platforms such as
Facebook Twitter Instagram. And
social networking events we are
also encouraging our other
stakeholders such as community
based organizations. That we
partner with to educate the
members about the census and C.
believes it is important that
there is a complete count in
the twenty twenty census. A
written testimony that
describes our out reaching more
detail will be submitted after
this- hearing thank you. Very
much. A good afternoon- I'm Sam
re from the nonprofit community
connect labs which has been
providing census technology to
California counties for the
past two years we appreciate
the state's a robust funding to
support us since twenty twenty-
region course your time today
in this meeting. As we've heard
today since hiring California
is urgently behind more since
his job applicants are still
needed than can fit in the
staples center to continue the
metaphor of today.
Approximately forty thousand
candidates in el Los Angeles
county according to the data
share today and tens of
thousands more in California.
California must act now to make
sure that there are enough
enumerators hired. Recruiting
department. Recruiting and
helping get hired more
qualified local candidates is
potentially one of the highest
impacts a community member can
have today the government an
organization or an individual
as each is tasked with counting
three hundred people in a
community community can I close
my organization has developed
our field staff recruiter with
input from the census bureau to
address hiring problems such as
the long opaque in leaky
federal hiring process starting
with the application that must
be completed online in one
sitting. The process includes
additional assets has an
appointment for fingerprinting
or submission of selective
service information the field
staff recruiter is a mobile
messaging solution Taylor to
engage and support candidates
from local hard count
communities to the online
application in hiring processes
by providing brief training
videos automatically remind
candidates to complete the
application and updating them
about the status of their
application it's easily
distributed by statewide by
regional networks for schools
nonprofits and government
agencies. The field suffer
critter has already been
piloted in California and
Arizona with excellent results
C. C. L. solution has
interacted with over a thousand
participants 49% of him speak a
second language representing
over forty four languages in
California we partnered with
the California adult education
program or Cape recruited more
than six hundred candidates
through twenty of their Cape
schools Cape wants to work with
the state wide we need more
funding. We believe that
appropriate tech tools can be a
force for multiplier of be a
force multiplier for good
technology can help remover
less and many of the barriers
to participation discuss in
this meeting today we believe
that we should leverage this
technology to make it as easy
as possible for individuals
across the state to apply for
and follow through on
applications for since this
job. Thank you. Thank you. All
right a single further of
public comment- I'll reiterate
my reiterate my thank you to-
this somebody Senate and Long
Beach staffs. And we are
adjourned thank you. Okay